[Musique]
marc endeweld bonsoir bon ça vous
recevant pour une chaîne interne et qui
s'appelle singer view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement je m'appelle
donc marc endeweld journaliste je
travaille notamment pour le journal
économique la tribune pour le mensuel le
monde diplomatique pour d'autres
publications et j'écris des livres
enquêtes notamment le dernier qui
s'appelle l'emprise la france sous
influence et c'est déjà mon cinquième
livre voilà comment il s'appelait lundi
dernier alors ça a été le dernier
c'était le grand manipulateur les
réseaux secrets de macron et l'avant
dans l'avant dernier c'était
l'avant dernier c'était l'ambigu
monsieur macron qui était le premier
livre une enquête sur emmanuel macron
quand il n'était que ministre de
l'économie ses sorties en 2015
et aujourd'hui on vous reçoit pour le
dernier qui est un pavé t'avais qui te
fait plus de 600 pages un peu moins un
peu moins ça s'appelle l'emprise
pourquoi avoir écrit ce bouquin pourquoi
avoir autant chercher pourquoi avoir
fait un constat chirurgicale de nos
instituts certaines de nos institutions
c'est un bouquin qu'on a vu pour moitié
qui se tient bien en main c'est un bel
objet
pourquoi encore un bouquin qui me donne
le cafard
ou la déprime ou
l'insatisfaction la colère la prise de
conscience tout simplement a
déjà parce que c'est le c'est mon métier
de journaliste de délivrer des de
dévoiler des coulisses mais également de
faire des constats de 2
d'essayer de chercher la vérité
et le le point de départ il est de ce
nouveau livret est multiple parce que
donc je précise ce n'est pas un
troisième livre sur emmanuel macron même
s'il est sur la la couverture
parce que je reviens dans le passé donc
je parle aussi d autres présidents
je reviens dans passé dont je parle
aussi nicolas sarkozy de françois
hollande je reviens également parfois
sous l'époque de françois mitterrand
je parle de l'état français
effectivement du rapport de l'état
français de nos institutions
aux enjeux internationaux
et le point de départ c'est à la fois en
2019 parce que c'est un projet qui date
de dia maintenant un peu plus de deux
ans
dans mes différentes enquêtes sur monde
des affaires à paris et autres il y as
je m'aperçois que les tensions entre la
chine et les états unis sont plus en
plus croissante à l'époque la presse
française en parle encore assez peu ou
sur un sous un angle uniquement ça
commence sous un angle de guerre
économique pur mais pas trop encore sur
des tensions systémique entre les deux
superpuissances et moi au contraire dans
les différentes enquêtes que je fais je
vois que c'est un sujet qui monte qui ne
cesse de monter et jeu j'essaye de
comprendre
la petite place du pays france dans ce
choc là et en fait c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle aussi sous l'emprise c'est que
c'est la france sous l'emprise des deux
superpuissances
la chine les etats unis comment
finalement le pays est écartelé entre
ses deux superpuissances mais du fait
également de nos choix de nos choix
stratégiques de
de nos choix à courte vue parmi les
dirigeants économiques et politiques
français donc on est on est dans
l'histoire longue mais également le
temps présent le bilan du quinquennat
macron
voilà et puis justement sur le
quinquennat macron un autre point de
départ de l'enquète qui - géopolitique
est moins grand angle on va dire
c'est aussi la petite histoire les coûts
liste des acteurs de l'ombre
notamment dans le monde du renseignement
j'ai rencontré pas mal de
redire d'espions ou de gens qui peuvent
se définir comme tels des spécialistes
de l'enseignement économique des aussi
des guides hurd influence dans tout un
tas d'acteurs qui dans l'ombre
travaillent pour défendre certains
intérêts et non c'est aussi un autre
point de départ c'est lé constat que
j'ai pu faire quand j'ai travaillé sur
la sphère bina là
où je me suis aperçu que derrière la
ferme et nana mais comme d'autres
affaires qui ont parcouru le quinquennat
il pouvait exister d interférence
étrangère de différents types que j'ai
d'ailleurs pas totalement tout déterminé
tout découvrir
découverte et ça donne ce livre qui est
un peu un il ya plusieurs livres dans un
livre en fête
livre dans un livre je vais je vais vous
lire le préambule le vieux monde se
meurt le nouveau nom d' tarder à
apparaître et dans ce clair obscur
surgissent les monstres antonio gramsci
pourquoi avoir nisa
c'est un clin d'oeil justement là pour
le coup c'est un clin d'oeil direct
notamment à notre président de la
république qui a promu le nouveau monde
en termes de communication dans sa
précédente campagne présidentielle en
2017 en expliquant qu' il allait tout
révolutionner que c'était quelqu'un qui
venait de lier ont bâti en tout cas
qu'il qu'il était l'homme neuf
est en fête bon c'est vrai que cela je
dépeins d'une manière assez cliniques
les ses échecs sur le plan diplomatique
mais également son incapacité
échec
ça n'a pas marché ça n'a pas marché oui
mais enfin ils tous les ans en tout cas
son incapacité à
mobiliser la population sur un autre
projet et avoir un projet cohérent
finalement tu es en fait
parce que dans un monde complexe tel que
tu allais quel est le nôtre
on ne peut pas avoir l'ambition tout
seul de tout changer c'est pas possible
indépendamment de la ligne politique de
toute manière et on attendait on l'a vu
entre son discours sur un stock
nationaux début du quinquennat et ce qui
s'est passé entre les deux et d'ailleurs
qui a percuté mon enquête je veux parler
de la pandémie on est passé à un
discours aujourd'hui dans che dirigeants
économiques français notamment mais même
politique mais on n'a qu'à le voir lors
des prochains débats on valoir de haut
tout le monde parle de souveraineté
économique tout d'un coup tout le monde
parle de deux d'intérêts nationaux
stratégiques
tout le monde parle de
réindustrialisation du pays les
thématiques qui était pas absente du
débat parce qu'il y avait décidé des
signaux d alerte il y avait des qui
était considéré comme d'extrême droite
d'extrême droite parfois on parlait de
ça on disait souverainiste parfois aussi
moi j'ai pas fait un bouquin idéologique
j'ai fait juste une enquête justement
qui montre par exemple je perds ma sur
le terrain européen comment les
allemands défendent que leurs intérêts
nationaux
très clairement
voilà et donc on peut être européen et
défendre ses intérêts nationaux c'est
pas incompatible salle et voilà ce n'est
pas se poser cette question là ce n'est
pas un problème est justement le souci
en france c'est qu'on a tendance à faire
des beaux débats sur des concepts donc
on se réfugie derrière il ya la casaque
bleue rouge il ya les souverainistes et
les européistes tout le monde se fout
sur la gueule mais en fait
pendant ce temps là on n'a pas de
stratégie on parle pas du concret des
faits
on n'est pas pragmatique
mais on n'est pas à jour les enjeux
stratégiques
et les ou l'efficacité ou l'inefficacité
de certains choix
et donc
donc la france souffre entre guillemets
de sa
souffre de
projeter de pas se projeter ne pas avoir
projets d'avenir
symptomatique wydad dans le
oui c'est ça dans la dans la réaction à
courte vue
dans la polémique médiatique qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui le bruit médiatique
on est un pays avec beaucoup de chaînes
d'information continue enfin dite
d'information continue
ça se transmet sur les réseaux sociaux
tout ça c'est un mélange
mai
mais au bout du compte finalement le
débat public est assez pauvre sur les
vrais sujets et c'est donc pour revenir
à votre interpellation sur ce n'est pas
sale
et bien
en fait
les questions de souveraineté économique
enfin tels qu'on peut les qualifier
comme ça les questions stratégiques
ça avoir autant
par rapport à la question de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
la question des emplois des emplois
industriels mais des emplois tout court
est donc en fait c'est la vie des gens
ça concerne la vie des gens et ça a des
conséquences sur la vie des gens voilà
donc on a un peu tendance à l'oublier et
en plus comme c'est des sujets complexes
plupart du temps
et c'est parfois un reproche qu'on le
fait sur des enquêtes à c'est trop
complexe et trop compliqué de trouver ce
très simple voilà bah oui oui mais je
crois que c'est assez simple en fait
alors oui il ya beaucoup de parfois
d'acteurs et beaucoup d'enjeux les
choses sont complexes n'est pas simple
parfois enfin au sens
le monde est complexe mais justement
c'est c'est mon travail de démêler le
faux du vrai bon ça c'est une
lapalissade mais notamment surtout les
les différents enjeux parfois
antagonistes sur un même sujet et
est généralement c'est bon il ya
toujours des enquêtes qui sont faites
bien évidemment mais voilà le mon livre
là par exemple un monde donnait parle de
corruption et d'enjeux de la corruption
sur les grands contrats internationaux
pas uniquement d'armement mais également
on va dire tous les grands contrats
internationaux
que les entreprises françaises peuvent
passer à l'étranger à plus de 200
millions de dollars voilà c'est ça alors
de 100 millions de dollars on le sait
parce que c'est plus notamment les les
priorités d'un pays comme les etats-unis
de regarder tous les contrats de plus de
200 millions de dollars et d'espionner
sur ces contrats là et de
potentiellement parfois déstabiliser les
entreprises qui les passe au nom de ce
qu'on appelle la compliance conformité
en anglais et donc de cette
instrumentalisation là pour le coup
juridique
de la lutte contre la corruption qui est
louable la lutte contre la corruption
bien évidemment mais
il faut aussi prendre en compte les
enjeux d'intérêt entre états entre
groupes stratégiques et ça ça fait
partie de toute une partie de l' enquête
c'est à dire comment une superpuissance
aux grandes démocraties comme les
etats-unis ont lancé depuis une
vingtaine trentaine d'années c'est assez
anciens en réalité une guerre économique
tout azimuts y compris à l'égard d' de
ses alliés
tout simplement pour garder et conserver
le leadership économique au niveau
mondial et donc ça passe bien évidemment
par des attaques juridiques à l'encontre
de grands groupes dans livre d'ailleurs
j'évoque pas que alstom j'évoque alcatel
bien évidemment pourra revenir dessus
parce que c'est même au delà d'alstom je
crois qu alcatel c'est un cas
extrêmement emblématique de nos
faiblesses structurelles aujourd'hui du
pays france et même européens de
l'espace européen mais bien il ya tout
l'épisode sur airbus
finalement qui a été moins médiatisé que
la sphère alstom en termes de
déstabilisation économique
et donc où les américains ont joué un
grand rôle de déstabilisation
notamment d'un point de vue juridique
mais je pense que c'est une affaire
encore peut-être plus grave en termes de
d'espionnage économique qui en termes de
déperdition des savoir faire et de ce
qu'on appelle à la recherche et
développement et comme justement stinat
faire moins spectaculaire on va dire que
le rachat par ji des activités d'alstom
- symbolique peut-être
plus complexe plus technique c'est
apparu moins dans le débat alors que la
déstabilisation d'airbus il ya quelques
années
ça remonte à en fait entre 2014 et 2017
a failli coûter très très cher au groupe
même si maintenant le groupe vend
beaucoup d'appareils civils
et laisse toujours des traces
considérable sur ce qu'était le groupe
airbus
il ya énormément d'anecdotes d'histoires
de recherche dans ce bouquin on va
commencer par le premier premier
chapitre le quai d'orsay grosse fatigue
ok
pourquoi avoir commencé par le quai
d'orsay c'était c'est la porte d'entrée
à tout ça c'est parce que c'est le point
pivot de notre affaiblissement
c'est par rapport à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure sur on se réfugie dans
les symboles et surtout dans les dents
les débats de concept en france
le conduire dans l'imaginaire collectif
les diplomates français
ont pour mission de tenir le rang du
pays quoi et donc
est donc
d'ailleurs ça fait partie du moyen de
l'inconscient y compris des de nos chez
nos diplomates c'est à dire
il ya encore certains d'entre eux pas
tous mais ont un référentiel de il faut
il faut que la france tienne son rang
dans le concert des nations
doit être légitime à tenir son siège de
sécurité au conseil de sécurité
nationale des nations unies et par
ailleurs si une manière de regarder la
relation internationale qui est très
classique
et on le voit d'ailleurs sur le dernier
dossier sur l'ukraine où on a
l'impression que on est encore
sur la belle palabres xviiie siècle
certaine manière alors que les enjeux
économiques les enjeux stratégiques
sont de plus en plus considérable dans
les rapports d'état à état et ce qui est
très intéressant par rapport au quai
d'orsay c'est bien évidemment il ya un
malaise intrinsèque hockey depuis très
longtemps pour plein de raisons que
j'évoque et notamment des choses qui
sont liées à la vème république et au
domaine réservé du président la
république mais ça c'est quelque chose
qui est assez classique où toute la
décision dans le domaine réservé de la
diplomatie est concentrée à l'elysée ce
qui est assez étonnant la dent dans l'
enquête c'est de voir comment le
secrétaire général alexis colère
principal collaborateur d'ayman al mc
ont également eu énormément de marge de
manoeuvre pour imposer sa patte sur la
diplomatie française ce qui n'est pas
forcément le rôle d'un secrétaire
général de l'elysée chatou ils n'ont
pris sur le quai oui d'une certaine
manière
emmanuel macron lui même s'est plaint de
la déloyauté de ces diplomates
là il faut se souvenir en août 2019 à la
conférence des ambassadeurs
il lâche un tonitruant
c'est l'état profond en pointant
certains diplomates qui
qui sont considérés comme davantage
atlantiste pro américain est en tout cas
qu'ils n'étaient pas favorables plus que
ça ou plutôt sceptiques à une reprise
d'un dialogue bilatéral soutenu avec la
russie avec l'animé routine
je pense que emmanuel macron était dans
une posture victimaire à ce moment là on
regarde du fonctionnement de la vème
république parce qu'en réalité le quai
au regard de la puissance et du pouvoir
concentraient à l'elysée n'a pas grand
vin ne peuvent ne peut pas faire grand
chose en fait ils peuvent ralentir
l'action diplomatique de la france sur
tel ou tel sujet mais en fait ça se joue
à la marge le malaise en tout cas des
diplomates français est plus profond de
mon point de vue certes parce que il ya
certains grands diplomates qui se sont
inscrits dans une tradition
antagonistes par rapport à la tradition
du quai historique en tout cas ces
cinquante dernières années et qui
n'étaient pas forcément sur un
référentiel de l'indépendance du pays
donc qu'ils étaient sûrs plutôt un
référentiel de l'alignement aux états
unis
donc c'est ce qu'on a appelé les
néoconservateurs
c'est alors ils se définissent pas comme
tel au caire et après on pourra revenir
peut-être qu'ils sont ils que vous ok
mais derrière ses juges une influence et
de positionnement idéologique ok il ya
un affaiblissement même de la fonction
du diplomate pourquoi parce que dans le
monde interconnecté où en fait les chefs
d'état peuvent se parler directement par
messagerie messagerie dite sécurisée
en fait ils contournent allègrement la
fonction des diplomates ils se parlent
en direct ça peut provoquer d'ailleurs à
mon avis beaucoup de quiproquos
d'incompréhension
mais tout le temps long de la diplomatie
est battu en brèche également par la
médiatisation des relations
internationales
et par ailleurs il ya une autre
faiblesse aujourd'hui la fonction
diplomatique qui est profonde et qu'on
retrouve dans d'autres pays y compris
notamment démocratiques notamment aux
états unis par exemple département
d'état est dans un sale état en fait
pourquoi parce que et aux états unis
même il ya une concentration du pouvoir
diplomatique maintenant la maison
blanche pas sur tous les sujets mais
quand même et pourquoi parce que en fait
on a assisté ces dernières années à une
militarisation des relations
internationales et on va dire un regard
sur le monde
via la kz2 à dire des menaces des
menaces extérieures
la lutte contre le terrorisme
on a pu le voir au sahel avec la france
et donc c'est le pouvoir des militaires
ou du renseignement capri souvent le pas
dans la décision étatique sur sur les
diplomates il ya un élément purement
objectif le quai qui a toujours souffert
d'un sous investissement chronique
alors qu'on a le trou soit disant le
troisième réseau international de
d'ambassades et de consulats donc on a
encore un gros réseau diplomatique
loew le budget du quai même s'il a été
un tout petit peu relevé ces derniers
mois a historiquement a toujours été
assez c 'est toujours été un peu un des
parents pauvres de l'état français et
[Musique]
et donc sur la période récente sur l'a
10 dernières années
le nombre de diplomates a un peu fléchi
mais le nombre d'agents de la dgse a
doublé et même il ya cgp les chiffres en
tête mais en tout cas il ya un
inversement et courbe s'inverse entre le
service extérieur et les renseignements
et le quai d'orsay est donc c'est très
mal vécu du côté du quai d'orsay
alors aussi avec une augmentation du
nombre d'agents de la dgse par le
renseignement électronique et
l'espionnage électronique
ce mal-être compte est opérationnel il
traduit comment ils et les gens sont
déprimés ou ceux plus prendre de
décisions ils font pu remonter
l'information comment ça se passe ils
ont après oui déjà en terme d' analyse
de remontée d'informations
qu'ils ont l'impression qu'ils servent
plus à rien
moi j'ai rencontré plusieurs anciens
ministres des affaires étrangères dans
le cadre de l'enquêté
par exemple j'ai rencontré alain juppé
j'ai rencontré hubert védrine j'ai
rencontré dominique de villepin par
exemple et je sais qu'elle a un super
mec m'a dit la chose suivante à un
moment donné de l'enquète m'a dit
je tenais à lire toutes les notes qui me
remontait des diplomates et de les
annoter
et j'ai des diplomates qui se
souvenaient de l'époque des deux époques
juppé parce qu'elle était deux fois mis
les affaires étrangères
tous les ministres des affaires
étrangères ne le fait pas cet effort ne
sont pas ne faut pas cet effort là
de prise en compte de des remontées
d'informations des ambassades des
analyses faites par les uns par nos
diplomates
il ya également dans la tradition
diplomatique française a parfois un
billet c'est à dire on est dans la
diplomatie du prince ou en fait on
plaque nos propres biens
institutionnelle française c'est-à-dire
survalorise les institutions politiques
sur souvent les sociétés civiles ou les
acteurs privés dans les différents pays
concernés et donc on loupe énormément
d'informations ou de soft power auprès
des acteurs locaux des différents pays
alors que ça serait finalement une
stratégie assez simple à mener alors
bien évidemment il ya toujours tout un
travail fait par la direction culturelle
du quai d'orsay
ces français à l'étranger
nous oui oui les freins et les lycées
françaises baissent les surtout il ya
une sorte de privatisation sous main
justement par manque de budget qui passe
par le fait que les six lycées français
deviennent de plus en plus contenir
200 plus en plus liés aux élites locales
des différents pays
kibaki par des dons privés
par les parents qui donnent et par
ailleurs il ya un diplomate qui m'avait
expliqué la chose suivante c'est que les
les
le personnel et les professeurs étaient
plus forcément de la même catégorie
et donc il y avait un affaiblissement et
ça c'est des investissements à long
terme qui sont moins réalisé aujourd'hui
depuis quelques années et sur le long
terme on le paye enfin tout cas la
france le paye
alors que là on serait totalement dans
une stratégie de soft power
finalement assez simple à mettre en
place finalement assez peu coûteuse en
réalité
et qui dans le monde dans ce monde là
ils payent pas hyper médiatisé en
manière de l'internet et de la
globalisation est essentiel et
donc le voilà le malaise est multiple et
il se traduit du côté du club en plein
de choses il se traduit par le fait qu'
il ya de plus en plus un mélange des
genres du côté des hauts diplomates pas
du corps intermédiaires du quai mais les
plus aux grands diplomates sont dans des
jeux de pouvoir très important vis à vis
des élites politiques puis et puis
surtout il passe au dans le privé ils ne
finissent pas leur carrière hockey est
double
c'est donc j'essaye de france à
washington oui vous voulez parler de
gérard araud je crois qu il y pas dans
une ensuite il épatera il a travaillé
effectivement pendant
je crois deux ans
comité éthique du groupe et nassau qui
est le groupe israélien qui est des
produits logiciels espions pegasus tout
à fait
voilà on est dans ce genre de mélange
des genres c'est bien de voir un ancien
diplomate à un comité des sages celle du
soft power
en tout cas oui en tout cas il ya
s'éveille elle va et vient là il faut
savoir par exemple sur les événements
des ambassades à l'étranger et des
ambassades françaises à l'étranger et
ces événements là sont de plus en plus
sponsorisé par des grands groupes
français qui ont eux mêmes leurs
intérêts et parfois divergents avec
notre diplomatie en fait ces saloperies
ce qui est sûr notre diplomatie des
intérêts extérieurs qui nous pousse à
gauche ou à droite des puissances qui
nous pousse à gauche à droite en fait la
parole de la france n'existe plus en
tout cas un des constats de l'enquète
c'est que les intérêts privés sont de
plus en plus imbriquées aux intérêts
étatiques et interétatiques au aux
enjeux énergétiques industriels et
stratégiques des états ça c'est un
mouvement mondial d'une certaine manière
mais ça se percutent plus
particulièrement sur la france de mon
point de vue parce que justement
commencé enfin comme les dirigeants de
ce pays pas uniquement politique mais
sont réfugiées facilement dans une
idéologie néolibérale et surtout
pro-entreprises enfin pour cette île une
certaine manière du marché enfin voilà
on est dans les grands concepts on n'est
pas dans la on est pas dans la vraie vie
en fait est en fait en se réfugiant dans
ses concepts là on laisse dépérir
la situation de mon point de vue
parce que parce qu'en face les autres
ils fourbissent leurs armes et pendant
que et pendant que nous en fait enfin la
france n'a pas n'a pas n'a pas comme je
le dis dans le livre on la france s'est
désarmé petit à petit temps d'une d'un
point de vue industriel que d'un point
de vue stratégique tant du point de vue
du renseignement par exemple hier il ya
tout un développement dans le livre où
j'explique comment puisque quand même et
ça m'intriguait donc comment finalement
lorsqu'on appelle le renseignement
économique en tout cas l'activité
d'espionnage dans le domaine économique
avait été pendant des années des années
des années délaissé par la dgse ou par
là déjà si ce n'est que très récemment
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron a décidé de
de d'en faire une des priorités de nos
services de renseignement avec quelques
budgets alloués depuis depuis que
finalement très récemment au cours du
quinquennat mais en fait de prendre 20
ans
il n'était pas question en tout cas ce
n'était pas du tout une priorité de
faire du renseignement économique et
surtout pas à l'encontre du grand frère
américain ce qui n'a pas toujours été le
cas
et c'est ça qui est ça qui est étonnant
il faut rappeler l'histoire
voilà le général de gaulle parce que
voilà c'est ça fait partie des des
inconscients de tous les responsables
politiques tout le monde parle de de
gaulle de l'extrême droite à l'extrême
gauche même à peine une certaine manière
ça je voulais finir tout
voilà en tout cas bon on parle de de
gaulle voilà donc on parle de de gaulle
mais de gaulle par exemple dans sa
stratégie d'indépendance nationale
notamment sur l'aéronautique sur le
nucléaire et sur également et
télécommunications avait décidé dans
cette stratégie d'indépendance nationale
de demander aux dec donc le service
extérieur à l'époque l'ancêtre dgse de
mener une offensive considérable les
gardes et des intérêts américains et
donc la france a espionné le programme
nucléaire américain ils ont espionné nos
espions à l'époque ont espionné
des grandes entreprises américaines
les américains d'ailleurs se sont pas
laissés faire ils ont souvent longtemps
considéré a déjà ce comme trop proche de
l'union soviétique
il a considéré que la dgse était grand
krainer paraît par les espions
soviétiques était calme et avec la
sphère fin ou le tout à fait ce qui a
été calmée par la sphère farwell on le
rappelle la sphère farwell c'était un
transfuge
union soviétique qui passait par des
contacts de la société peut-être thomson
à l'époque qui a été en partie traités
par déjà celui surtout pas par la la la
la dst
ça c'est aussi un autre élément assez
méconnu comment la dst donc le contre
espionnage a toujours été dans la lutte
contre le communisme plutôt proche de
services américains et justement dans la
sphère farwell
c'était l'espion russe enfin pas les
semis en le transfuge russe qui est
qui dévoilait tout un réseau de
renseignements économiques de l'union
soviétique en europe et aux états unis
donc c'est des centaines de noms qui ont
été dévoilées et à l'époque en fait
c'était un test de confiance d'ailleurs
vis-à-vis de nos alliés américains parce
que c'était le problème président
françois mitterrand on est en 81 82 et
françois mitterrand avait le programme
commun avec les communistes au
gouvernement
et donc il a décidé de transmettre les
informations dont il était le
dépositaire
aux américains à reggane mais en fait
pour la petite histoire dans ce qu'on
m'a appris
ça s'est relativement connu en tout cas
par des spécialistes et des initiés mais
pour la petite histoire avant même que
mitterrand donne les informations aux
américains les américains avaient déjà
l'information parce que la dst leur
avait déjà donné l'information et donc
ça ça a permis aux américains de tester
la loyauté de françois mitterrand à
l'époque lé regard comment allez-vous
farouk el fois là mais c'est
vrai après la question de comment la dst
à traiter ces sources oui alors en plus
dense qu'on m'a expliqué y avait des
fins il ya toujours des bagarres dans le
récit entre les anciens de l'as déjà
ceux qui disent ça s'est passé comme ça
les anciens la dst qui disent ça s'est
passé comme ça
voilà mes mais en tout cas ce qui s'est
passé ensuite par la suite pour revenir
à ce qu'on disait sur renseignement
économique
le patron
nommé fin du renseignement extérieur
nommé par mitterrand à l'époque
j'ai oublié son prénom mais c'est
monsieur marion à l'époque
avait lui aussi sous mitterrand engagé
dès
tout un programme d'espionnage
économique à l'égard des états unis ça
s'est terminé un peu dans la catastrophe
parce que le fbi a il ya
30 ans dévoilé tout où tous nos contacts
aux états unis afin dé à 80 et là il ya
eu une sorte de yalta entre guillemets
entre les services occidentaux en tout
cas français et américain et en gros les
américains ont fait comprendre aux
français aux petits français qu' il
fallait arrêter de les espionner quoi et
depuis
c'est tout un angle mort du
renseignement français c'est à dire que
et on le voit sur une affaire qui a
défrayé la chronique récemment dont je
parle dans le livre c'est la faire des
sous marins australiens
parce que en fait tout le monde s'est
étonné du fait que l'on ne soit pas plus
que ça a tenu au courant du coup de
trafalgar on va dire quand sur le lv la
manière dont les américains nous ont
contourné
mais en fait j'ai vu
quelqu'un de haut placé dans
l'enseignement qui m'expliquait que que
ils n'osaient plus
faire de l'espionnage auprès enfin dont
la cible
sont elles les américains puisque en
fait ils ont peur des représailles enfin
d'être découvert et des représailles
donc en fait il ya sa note simplement le
notre niveau dans le monde durant dans
le monde du renseignement en face au
plus bas voilà face à la toute-puissance
face à la toute puissance américaine au
renseignement électronique américain qui
est juste considérables et
donc voilà ça replace les choses dans
leur contexte
de ce point de vue là la france est
devenue une puissance de boyer
d'impuissance oui c'est une belle
formule c'est plutôt ça après on peut le
regretter comme on peut considérer ça
comme
la logique de l'histoire mais
en tout cas il c'est tout l'objet de
l'enquète c'est ça fait partie
ce référentiel d'indépendance notamment
depuis la pandémie de tout un tas de
discours politiques
emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon aux
émaux mais mme pécresse pas tout le
monde en parle de l'indépendance du pays
le fils de notre outil de l'autonomie
stratégique
non je suis pas sûr qu'il soit trop tard
mais
mais il va falloir se pencher sur le
sujet mais même le roux de bézieux le
patron du medef que vous avez reçue
récemment
parle de planification écologique et de
réindustrialisation et de souveraineté
économique maintenant il a fait un
ouvrage sur de gaulle donc la boucle est
bouclée mais
moscou sur l'ansé du brick
mais là sur ce que j'ai racontée là
n'ont en général
on la dit quand ça se fait que nos
entreprises se font ouvrir comme ça ah
oui on l'a un peu secoué abbas a de
toute manière les grands groupes
français sont toujours encore très
naïvement peut équiper
invraisemblablement peu formés
et puis dans ces grands groupes français
par rapport à la guerre juridique que
j'évoquais
et ça c'est des grands en grand dans le
dire on va dire des grands messieurs
c'est souvent des messieurs s'est
parfois des femmes mais
qui ont connu les arcanes ou qui
connaissent toujours les arcanes du
grand commerce international
qui sont pas forcément tous blancs 1 ces
gens connaissent beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de secrets d'état me direz
qu'ils me disaient qu aujourd'hui dans
les grands groupes stratégiques français
par exemple je peins moi je pense ça on
a parlé d' airbus l'épisode airbus est
intéressant mais on peut plus penser à
thales par exemple
c'est la peur qui prédomine et les
management c'est à dire que en fait il
faut tout passé à la moulinette de la
conformité juridique
alors ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ya
pas des moyens détournés et les
américains le font déjà eux aussi très
bien
on va dire de faire passer quelques
fluidité on va dire ça comme ça
mais voilà aux etats unis c'est
finalement c'est beaucoup plus assumer
en interne quoi
ils jouent avec le droit les américains
mais ils s'affairent ils sont très forts
pour ça c'est vrai c'est leur bras armé
c'est leur bras armé et nous mais on
shore tu avec des tongs avec l'âge sans
crème solaire
c'est c'est un peu déprimant de se voir
dépouiller à 30 ans parce que on
n'anticipe rien sur les questions de
renseignement économique
n'anticipe rien sur notre projection on
ouvre une parenthèse entre vous et moi
ça fait quel effet de se voir
dans un pays qui est absolument
magnifique qui est la france avec
une élite
qui ne fait que faire qui ne fait que
perdurer et faire perdurer le ronron
quotidien de nos institutions
quand ils se retrouvent par on va
revenir sur le co vite parce qu'il ya
une petite partie sur le coït dans le
bouquin pourrait trouver très
intéressant
quand ils se retrouvent par rapport à
face un élément exotiques extérieur qui
ne rentrent pas dans leur prolongation
du ronron quotidien
payés avec nos impôts dans les salons
feutrés de la république ils savent plus
gérer les utilisent des cabinets privés
qu'est ce que ça fait de voir un pays
comme la france
ressemble et un petit peu à ce moment
très calme de lexus de l'effondrement de
l'ex union soviétique
alors
à titre personnel parce que je l'emploie
parfois notamment suite à cette enquête
là la comparaison
l'union soviétique finissante je la
trouve assez juste parce qu'en fait
c'est l'ensemble de l'architecturé
institutionnelle et également de la
gérontocratie qui
nous gouvernent malgré les jeunes
pousses en marché et notre jeune
président mais notre jeune président a
beaucoup de conseillers très vieux et
des conseillers parfois informel très
vieux
d'ailleurs on a pu le voir à belfort il
était accompagné de jean pierre
chevènement
qui a assuré le storytelling pour
expliquer que emmanuel macron n'était
que comme il l'a dit qu'un collaborateur
de françois hollande au moment de
l'affairé alsthom ce qui était quand
même un grand moment
ce qu'on va dire de communication donc
employer un terme très neutre tfou du
café ouais c'était fort que c'était fort
de café je pense que les ouvriers
d'alstom d'ailleurs était un peu
estomaqué derrière le culot des manuels
macron mais on pourra revenir après mai
mais
ce qui me frappe effectivement c'est que
on a l'impression que le système
institutionnel dont ça s'est sûr
d'autres enquêtes de toute manière
beaucoup de responsables responsables
politiques en tout cas des gens qui
connaissent bien la politique
notamment à droite dans la droite
républicaine d'ailleurs ils sont parfois
plus lucide que alex parti socialiste en
marche ou
ou à l'extrême droite ou à la gauche en
un mélange mais peut-être parce qu'ils
ont par tradition et rapport au pouvoir
une pratique de l'état plus plus assumer
manière plus plus de droite
c'est une crise de régime la vème
république est totalement à bout de
souffle et elle est à bout de souffle
notamment sur tous les enjeux
stratégiques on a décrit
un prout du retard oui c'est même plus
du retard
parce que par exemple sur un dossier
comme le nucléaire qu'on soit pour ou
contre d'ailleurs mais c'est la
catastrophe c'est à dire que
donc il ya tout un chapitre dans le
livre sur alors qu'ils s'appellent
convoitises nucléaire parce que
justement dans le livre je m'intéresse
aux influences étrangères et à cette
mondialisation de l'atome qui fait qu'
il n'y a pas d' équipes france mais il
ya des solutions russe des solutions
chinoise dans le nucléaire et des
solutions américaine qui se bataille
autour de notre nucléaire civil du
nucléaire civil français
donc là je raconte tout les coulisses
mais mais en fait actuellement
edf
l'ex framatome donc un qui a été
rachetée par edf qui était areva np
et tous les acteurs du nucléaire sont en
fait démunis parce que en termes
d'ingénierie de savoir-faire de
transmission de ce savoir faire
en fait beaucoup d'acteurs c'est pas moi
qui invente c'est la manière dont on
présente les choses en interne en off
les gens d'edf plein de gens qui ont pu
me parler en gros on ne sait plus
fabriquer un totalement une centrale
nucléaire
parce que toute façon on n'a pas les
équipes mis en place vous parliez des
cabinets privés ou de conseils ou
d'externalisation du savoir faire
là le président de la république a
annoncé la construction de père de qui
est le la terminologie présente à edf
notamment
c'est la terminologie aujourd'hui de
jean bernard lévy le patron d'edf
je vais employer une formule un peu
abrupte mais c'est l'image qu'on va
employer et que plusieurs spécialistes
mon employé
pour l'instant le père de saint paul
hunt et donc
il va falloir minima 10 ans d'études
pour lancer le programme dans les années
les réacteurs d'assez grandes puissances
je me suis énormément formes étranges
l'énergie nucléaire mais où parfois je
peux commettre des imprécisions mais en
tout cas on a on avait des réacteurs de
900 mégawatts sous licence américaine au
départ westinghouse
donc ça c'est les années 70 80 c'est le
plan messmer
la france avait une filière nucléaire
civil au graphite gaz sous de gaulle
mais elle était d'abord fait pour bon
pour la bombe et pour le plutonium pour
les différents
différents conduire matériaux
radioactifs utile à la bombe sauf que là
la filière graphite gaz le réacteur 1
fille de gaz et peu stable demande
beaucoup d'entretien beaucoup
d'investissements à l'utilisation et
donc c'est très cher pour une
utilisation commerciale et de fourniture
d'électricité et donc michel debré
premier ministre de de gaulle prend la
main et sourire voilà et bernard
esambert tout à fait c'est vrai qui est
un des pères de la filière nucléaire
civile dont bernard esambert spécialiste
de la guerre économique que j'ai
rencontré d'ailleurs non non dans le
cadre de l' enquête et croupit review
voilà et puis avait aussi à guillaume
avant il y avait plein de plein de plein
de gens
font le choix d'une solution technique
américaine en partie parce qu'ils font
choix de deux réacteurs à eau
pressurisée comme on dit qu'ils sont nos
réacteurs sur le parc civil français
fabriqué par l'américain westinghouse
general electric avait également une
proposition avec des réacteurs à eau
bouillante bon là je suis dans la
technique mais ça va plaire certaines
personnes que j'entre dans ces détails
là et les réacteurs westinghouse c'est
ce qui a amené la création de framatome
framatome c'est france amérique at home
dans tout le monde l'a oublié mais cette
origine là et fin 80 début 90 on va dire
les réacteurs sous licence par tout un
effet de contrat et parieurs de
francisation
des réacteurs en termes de brevets de
l'amélioration des process technique et
compagnie
donc les équipes françaises du nucléaire
à l'époque commence à franciser les
réacteurs notamment c'est ce qu'on a
appelé dans un 90 les palier n4 dans des
réacteurs de plus grande puissance mille
trois cent cinquante mille quatre cent
cinquante milliards en tout cas pour le
24 donc ces centrales notamment de
civaux et chose chose
et
là à l'époque dans un 90
des f&a framatome il y avait en me dit
elle et 15 mille ingénieurs qui étaient
sur le programme
la très récemment
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui a
fait des déclarations mois de janvier
très dur parce que ils ont tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a expliqué quoi dans le cadre
le patron de l'asn dans le cadre d'une
interview du monde
a quand même dit qu en gros
la filière industrielle française était
dans une nasse et que
et que ça soit la question de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement des centrales
nucléaires
de ce qu'on appelle aussi le grand
carénage
du niveau de mobilisation des réacteurs
nucléaires de plus en plus de réacteurs
à l'arrêt
pose maintenant un problème de sûreté
nucléaire concrètement ça veut dire en
gros derrière interview de la fin du
patron de l'asn et c'était carrément dit
plus que entre les lignes il disait en
tout cas avec ces mots choisis que
aujourd'hui on ne pouvait plus
totalement faire la sûreté nucléaire ne
pouvait plus être totalement respectée
dans le cadre de la défaillance
industrielle dans l'ensemble du parc ce
qui veut dire en gros que le patron de
l'asn a
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé ou a sorti le
parapluie pour dire si un incident
technique sur notre solution sur une de
nos centrales ont
on aura prévenu
c'est ces paroles qui sont fortes qui
sont graves
qui font pas énormément enfin s'ils
n'ont pas fait beaucoup débat en dehors
des initiés des gens de la grande
famille du nucléaire français
mais elle ne l ne sont pas anodines et
dans cette interview là
il explique qu'il va falloir embaucher
4000 ingénieurs par an pour
éventuellement
relancer la machine
donc
en face quand je dis en face donc
notamment je pense en chine
c'est des dizaines et des dizaines des
dizaines de milliers d'ingénieurs
qui est des pleins de réacteurs
nucléaires qui sont fabriqués à la
chaîne
aujourd'hui en chine et donc ça c'est
tout un aspect de l'enquète que j'ai
menée sur la manière dont ces dernières
années sur un sujet aussi stratégique
que les centrales nucléaires il ya eu un
consensus au coeur de l'état
a de tous niveaux
tant du côté des industriels que du côté
d'edf notamment mais également des hauts
fonctionnaires et jusqu'aux responsables
politiques qui étaient en fait si nous
voulons relancer le nucléaire donc là je
remonte à il ya 10 ans où nicolas
sarkozy mais également françois hollande
c'est ça qui m'a énormément surpris en
fait le consensus de l'époque c'était on
va faire les choses avec les chinois
alors c'est rage rage revient sur les
épisodes qui ont parfois été
journalistique m'en raconter la fameuse
syndicaliste d'areva marine carnicas u
qui a eu plusieurs problèmes parce
qu'elle attire et parfois la sonnette
d'alarmé en dévoilant des accords
d'ailleurs parfois tripartite entre
areva et edf et le groupe chinois cgnpc
le groupe nucléaire du sud de la chine
avec
lequel les français historiquement avait
l'habitude de collaborer voilà j'en vois
là et dansez dansez protocole d'accord
et accord que je me suis procuré est en
tout cas une géo qu'elle j'ai eu accès
je relate ça n'en livre il est
clairement spécifié que ce qui est mis
sur la table c'est justement la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
de la maintenance de nos centrales
nucléaires françaises donc
là au regard de tout le discours
aujourd'hui sur la réindustrialisation
là on est vraiment dans un
vrai trop spécial rétrospectivement
alors à l'époque c'était totalement
secret et d'ailleurs c'est la première
fois que ces protocoles d'accords sont
sont dévoilées en fait aussi précisément
que dans le cas dans le cadre de mon
livre mais en fait très clairement
ce qui m'a énormément frappé c'est que
le clan chemin qui a été appelé le clan
chinois du nucléaire notamment présents
edf alors pourquoi il était présent à
edf pour plein de raisons par rapport à
l'histoire d'edf par rapport à la chine
par rapport aux premiers réacteurs
français qui ont été vendus au chinois
début des années 90 enfin 80
mais également parce que edf qui était
dans la compétition avec areva donc là
on retrouve la guerre de la guerre
franco-française des réseaux
donc les chocs entre eux et grands
patrons arrêt de lauvergeon face à
proglio enfin ça on a vu ça parfois dans
la presse un bon et moi même j'ai écrit
dessus
donc il ya eu toute cette toute cette
bataille là donc chez certains côtés
d'edf l'idée était de passer par les
chinois pour contourner areva
il y avait les antilles au père il est
propre et enfin il y avait tout ce débat
là
et donc il y a entre nicolas sarkozy
françois hollande il ya des gens vont
tirer donc la sonnette d'alarmé même une
enquête des renseignements
je crois que c'était conjoint déjà
essayé seulement tout cas françois
hollande avait demandé une enquête sur
certaines personnalités de la sarkozie
qui avaient joué un rôle un peu
particulier sur d'éventuels transferts
technologiques aux chinois à la fin du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
enquête qu'à rester dans l'ombre
mais en fait une des découvertes de lors
de mon enquête s'éclate mais de la
relation entre la france et la chine sur
le nucléaire civil a lieu en fait sous
le quinquennat de françois hollande et
manuel valls et lança bus 6 1 un terrain
d'accord intergouvernemental en juin
dont l'un des axes de développement
stratégiques entre les deux pays ce
nucléaire
alors on peut le regretter s'en étonner
trouvé ça scandaleux au contraire
trouvez ça logique d'un point de vue
industriel moi il ya des gens
qu'ils connaissent bien des faits en
tout cas qui ont eu toute leur carrière
venait je pense notamment à quelques
personnes
qui ne font pas une question de principe
mais qui
de par leur expérience savent que quand
on assure des transferts technologies
auprès des chinois généralement au final
on se retrouve à poil prix pour parler
trivialement
et que
justement ils sont très forts pour
organiser toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et pour qu'ils
prennent l'avantagé comparatif sur nos
modestes moyens industriels de notre
côté donc en fait
joué cette carte là et il faut se
replacer dans le contexte on est il ya
dix quinze ans avant l'accident de
fukushima la chine est vu comme un
eldorado pour l'industrie nucléaire
française comme pour l'industrie
nucléaire internationale parce qu'il ya
aussi les américains qui sont présents
en chine
et alors il ya aussi toute une histoire
d'étonnantes que j'ai découverte sait
les liens sur nucléaires militaires
entre la chine les etats unis
du fait du rapprochement sous nixon
notamment entre la chine et des états
unis contre l'union soviétique et donc
l'imbrication de ses secteurs
stratégiques est beaucoup plus important
de qu'on pourrait le croire tout cas au
premier abord est
aujourd'hui dans le choc
chine-etats-unis que je présentais au
début dans cette tentative américaine un
peu de survie du pour préserver leur
leadership à tout prix de découplage de
leur économie avec la chine qu'at il
essaie de le faire
eh bien la france
qui a encore quelques industries
stratégiques aux quelques secteurs
stratégiques
en pâtit d'autant plus parce que on est
au coeur du sujet stratégique
dans la relation tout à avoir entre
entre la france et la chine donc au
milieu là les américains et les états
unis maintenant donc il faut replacer
faut regarder ça de cette manière là
parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
l'année dernière avant la sphère des
sous-marins
et c'est ça ma moi un petit peu amusé
parce que moi j'étais encore dans le
bain de
en plein dans l' enquête notamment
d'ailleurs durant l'été
profitant de la sortie du confinement
ce qui m'amuse et enfin je trouvais ça
un peu amusant mais
c'était que de voir que le premier signe
d'offensives américaine quand les
intérêts stratégiques français c'est pas
la faire des sous marins en septembre
c'est l'incident
nucléaire de taishan dévoilée par les
américains via la chaîne cnn le
lendemain du g7 où d'ailleurs il manuel
macron avait eu des paroles assez durs à
l'égard d'administration byden en
expliquant que le g7 n'était pas un club
anti chine et le lendemain de ces
déclarations la gauche peut te voilà
petit croche patte fortuitement
une fuite
journalistique la chaîne cnn dévoile que
il ya un accident potentiellement grave
à la centrale de taishan donc j'explique
centrale de taishan pas loin de hong
kong
c'est là où il ya les deux premiers ep
air france technologies françaises
vendues par les français qui ont été mis
en service par les chinois avant même
d'ailleurs nous les opère français ou
celui qui est en construction en
finlande et depuis d'ailleurs la
centrale est la centrale est à l'arrêt
et donc
bien évidemment que dans la guerre
informationnelle et donc dans cette
guerre froide économique stratégique
entre la chine et les états unis
qui n'a pas les même aspect que la
guerre idéologique de la vieille guerre
froide et qui a des aspects en tout cas
de 2
de dureté
commercial mais surtout aussi
stratégique on le voit la france se
retrouve piégé sur de multiples épisodes
de la farce
12h12 la fin oui enfin et et ça s'est
traduit alors ça c'est dans le cadre des
sous marins australiens ça s'est traduit
par le scandale diplomatique parce qu
emmanuel macron à utiliser ça pour en
faire un scandale diplomatique mais mais
en fait ce qui s'est passé sur incident
nucléaire de taishan et le dévoilement
par les américains
c'était pas mal non plus dans le genre
de croche patte ou la france petit pays
mais avec quelques secteurs encore
stratégique
se se retrouvent
se retrouve finalement un petit peu
embêté dans ce choc mondial actuel bien
évidemment que pour un pays comme
l'allemagne certes ils sont dans un lien
de dépendance économique à l'égard de la
chine notamment pour par rapport à
toutes leurs exportations
machines-outils voiture mercedes qui
partent en chine donc ils ont un lien
économique extrêmement fort avec avec la
chine d'ailleurs ça déplaît énormément
aux américains mais les américains ne
peuvent pas des aveugles peuvent pas
faire autrement mais en france déjà en
n'importe où des chinois donc on est
totalement dépendant
mais en plus
les quelques secteurs
sur lesquels on a pu collaborer avec les
chinois on peut penser aussi à
l'aéronautique un airbus une usine
d'assemblage
en chine
et bien dans tous ces secteurs là de
haute technicité
industriel à la fois on est sur des
secteurs donc en plein dans le choc
chine etats unis sur des choses
stratégiques et en plus on se retrouve
on se retrouve en difficulté
sur l'aéronautique par exemple
les chinois sont en train de développer
leur propre filière aéronautique donc le
groupe s'appelle comac
ils ont qui développe petit à petit ils
vont mettre sur le marché petit à petit
des avions de ligne ils sont en train de
le faire leur seul problème c'est la
certification internationale pour
l'instant de ses avions
mais c'est quand même un c'est quand
même un sujet précis et puis j'aborde
bien sûr dans le livre la question de
huawei et des télécommunications donc je
reviens sur mes pattes mais
la question des télécommunications est
là ce qui est fascinant
l'aspect miroir avec les états unis oui
et puis ce qui est fascinant c'est
je parlais désarmement ou d'auto des
armements de la france sur tous ces
sujets là c'est que le groupe alcatel
qui était leader des télécommunications
des réseaux dans un 90
a totalement été détruit quasiment et
bien sûr que là il y avait
des offensives notamment américaines à
l'encontre du groupe alcatel mais la
plupart des raisons qui expliquent cette
descente aux enfers sont liées à des
choix là pour le coup des dirigeants
français et des dirigeants d'alcatel
souvient de ses acheteurs rock sur
l'idéologie d entreprise sans usine
fabless et donc mais en fait il y avait
toujours des films sauf que les usines
d'alcatel elle était partie où elle est
c'est parti en chine et donc en fait
historiquement sur le temps long la
technicité et les moyens de réseau
développer chez huawei en fait si une
partie d'une partie de l'histoire
provient du fait que l'on a on a laissé
toute notre technologie partir dans la
donne dans les usines en chine pour des
raisons de courte vue d'argent facile de
poids des actionnaires et de l'idéologie
actionnariale et du et boursières sur
ces groupes là
et à l'époque ça convenait finalement à
au cercle de la raison comme on dit à
l'ensemble des dirigeants politiques et
économiques ça
c'est d'ailleurs olivier marc l'ex
on va dire 1 récemment un des rares
responsables politiques à tracer son
sillon sur les questions industrielles
d'une manière assez courageuse qui dit
qu'ils rapportent
qu'ils rapportent un dialogue avec un
ancien conseiller dominique strauss kahn
dans un 90 et qui dit toute façon les
ouvriers c'est sale donc il y avait
quand même derrière l'idée de
l'efficacité économique elle aussi
l'idée de on va se débarrasser de la
lutte des classes en france et donc on
veut surtout pas d' usine parce qu'avec
les usines on a des ouvriers
encore des ouvriers et donc
au regard de toutes les applications y
compris politiques on parle de
france des oubliés des gilet jaune de la
désindustrialisation du territoire c'est
même pas moi qui le dit c'est le sait le
grand patron du haut commissariat au
plan aujourd'hui françois bayrou alors
je précise que le haut commissariat au
plan institution mythique
d'un pays colbertiste comme la france a
été créée en 46
dans le cadre du programme du conseil
national de la résistance donc voilà ces
sujets là ce n'est pas qu'un sujet de
droite d'extrêmement c'est un sujet
d'ailleurs je pense que l'extrême droite
se plante beaucoup sur le sujet mais ça
on pourra reparler après mais c'est pas
un sujet de droite c'est un sujet aussi
de gauche cassé un conseil national de
la résistance et le haut commissariat au
plan ensuite qui a été promue par de
gaulle dans le cadre de la planification
économique est bien dans les derniers
rapports de signé par françois bayrou
c'est pas lui qui les écrit mais dans
les derniers rapports
il note
il dit que le pays
sur sa capacité industrielle
il fait une comparaison a ses provocs en
disant c'est c'est quasiment un an et
parfois envoie deux tiers mondisation
c'est-à-dire de totale dépendance
de nos besoins à l'égard de nos besoins
donc il ya le fameux exemple d
des chips eux
parce qu'on est producteur pommes de
terre excédentaire en production de
pommes de terre et alors qu'on a une
industrie agroalimentaire en fait on ne
fait fabriquer les chips ailleurs et
donc on importe les chips
voilà donc ça c'est un des exemples que
françois bayrou a mis en avant dans son
rapport mais j'ai oublié l'idée que je
voulais avancer sur sur ce que dit
bayrou par rapport à ce que j'ai
expliqué juste avant c'est un vieux clou
oui haut commissariat au plan j'ai
oublié
c'est que
tiers-mondisation et je sais plus j'ai
oublié l'idée mais en tout cas pour
revenir aux télécommunications ah ouais
je suis désolé de faire des parenthèses
ça c'est j'ai l'habitude
aujourd'hui
ouais ouais devient un problème
politique et économique politique au
sens diplomatique au sens géopolitique
parce que les états unis luttent contre
huawei en disant que c'est une menace de
sécurité notamment en termes de
renseignement électronique ils sont bien
placés pour le savoir jusqu'il fond
mais là la france est démuni parce que
on a plus on a pu alcatel et où
quasiment plus et quand on regarde
l'histoire
donc de ces 20 dernières années c'est de
descente aux enfers d'alcatel c'est
peut-être ce qui m'a le plus scandalisé
ou même au delà de la sphère alstom
parce que
on disposait d' alors bien sûr que la
somme c'est un joyeux joyau industriel
mais alcatel au regard des ce qu'on a
appelé les nouvelles technologies depuis
30 ans c'était un avantage comparatif
considérable pour le pays et on l'a
totalement bazarder et ce qui est très
très très impressionnant c'est que on
l'a bazarder jusqu'au bout parce que
donc je parle de huawei oui voilà j'ai
retrouvé l'idée
aujourd'hui donc on peut plus totalement
faire sans des acteurs étrangers sur les
télécommunications
alcatel lucent une enquête est déjà
devenu un groupe franco américain a été
racheté par le finlandais nokia mais là
aussi
emmanuel macron quand j'étais ministre
de l'économie il autorise le rachat par
le finlandais nokia
il parle des rebus de télécoms européens
où et en tout cas il parle de
souveraineté économique européenne
dit-il en réalité le groupe nokia comme
le groupe ericsson font fabriquer la
plupart de leurs de leurs produits
technologiques en chine
donc là on est quand même dans du faux
semblant assez considérable on est dans
des effets de com il avait demandé à ce
que le groupe nokia préserve l'emploi
industriel et surtout de recherche et
développement ce qui reste un petit peu
mais c'est en fait c'était en fait du
pipeau parce que tous les engagements
pris à l'époque par groupe nokia ont
aucun nom a été respectée
lannion en bretagne
enfin si tu les sites historiques
d'alcatel en recherche et développement
ont vu leur des sous-investissement
chronique et les syndicats craignent un
désengagement total du groupe nokia sur
sur la france
et là moi je me souviens parce que c'est
une histoire en fait que j'ai suivie
depuis très longtemps quand en 2015 je
vais l'ambigu monsieur macron et que
donc je suis les premiers pas du
ministre emmanuel macron
je rencontre un grand patron
considéré comme très proche des manuels
macron
à mon avis un peu trop considéré comme
proche des manades macron
plus aussi un conseiller
considérer également proche quand même
des manuels macron les deux m'alerte sur
la vente
la ventes d'alcatel lucent à nokia les
deux me dise
macron a fait une connerie et alors
pourquoi au delà même de toute
l'histoire du groupe alcatel
bas parce que il y avait une pépite
encore dans les activités de ce qui
restait d'alcatel de ces dernières
années une activité historique
d'ailleurs qui appartenait avant à la
compagnie générale d'électricité donc le
groupe cge qui a été créée en 1898
attention
qui est l activité de fabrication de
câbles sous marins voilà
je retombe toujours sur mes pattes et
donc ça tombe bien c'est un sujet qui
est donc
les câbles sous marins et en fait alors
ça ça fait partie des découvertes du
livre enfin en tout cas je sais que les
initiés sont au courant mais en tout cas
si des informations qui sont peu rendu
public et peu transmise au grand public
mais plusieurs choses donc
alcatel
donc maintenant nokia mais dispose d'une
filiale en france spécialisé dans les
câbles sous marins il ya une usine à
calais en fait historiquement
lusine de calais est très ancienne elle
date donc du 20e siècle mais même du
début du siècle
doit être la fin du 19ème début 20e je
sais plus quand ils ont commencé cette
activité de kamel était à fait elle est
très ancienne elle était liée à un autre
et un autre activité industrielle de la
cge ce qui s'appelle les câbles de lyon
donc c'était deux savoir-faire français
sur les câbles sous marins notamment
mais plus globalement sur les câbles
télécommunications dans les années 70-80
je crois ils sont passés à la fibre
optique
et on a une très grande technicité une
très grande maîtrise technique
parmi les meilleurs au monde dans l'
usine de calais
elle est aujourd'hui sous contrôle de
nokia qui fait l'objet de l'appétit
américain
régulier on va dire et donc les deux
personnes là le conseiller considéré
comme proche des manades maquereau et le
grand patron considéré comme proche de
néma normal qu'on me dise il a fait une
énorme connerie parce que on a perdu le
contrôle alors toujours il ya des
engagements 1 donc soit disant il ya des
petites closes pour préserver l'intérêt
national mais les deux personnes
s'étaient unanime pourtant encore une
fois proches et qu'on me disait ils ont
fait une énorme connerie parce qu'ils
ont lâché
une activité industrielle ultra
stratégique aujourd'hui aussi en termes
de renseignements et voilà c'est à dire
que là en 2015 ils me disent en gros dés
au lieu de parler trivialement mais on
est dans la merde parce que ça nous
donnait un avantage comparatif
sur la maîtrise de ses câbles sous
marins y compris en termes de
renseignements tout à fait
doudi petit voilà jeu j'écris ça mais
voyez tout à fait genre dans les détails
de tout ça est en fête alors pour
expliquer techniquement
ça passe à la fois par des tirs alors il
y aller il ya une technologie française
d'air qui s'appelle et son de cosmos qui
se résout couscous qui ce qui permet de
se planquer sur les câbles on va dire ça
comme ça et surtout de traiter le flux
d'informations qui passent
dans la fibre optique parce que c'est
des milliards de données qui passe en
continu donc je rappelle que les câbles
sous marins ses 99 % du trafic mondial
d'internet vous que c'est considérable
et
et donc il ya les sondes cosmoz qui
peuvent se brancher il ya ce qu'on
appelle les stations d'atterrage donc
c'est là où les câbles arrive sur les
continents enfin sur la terre quand il
voit là et y est mort voilà justement ça
c'est aussi un autre élément que j'ai
découvert et donc ça souvent branchés
câbles sous marins sur des espaces
portuaires pour pour des questions
logistiques parce qu'il faut de la place
pour traiter
mais aussi des centres de données il
faut de l'énergie enfin bon tout ça
coûte américains et chinois qui truquent
par la voilà tout à fait et donc
avec cette activité de câbles sous
marins d'alcatel on avait bien
évidemment la technicité
mais également la capacité de se
brancher à d'écouté et notamment la dgse
est donc là on on laisse on a laisser ça
comme ça passait il ya pas un crétin le
gouvernement qui lui a dit où il faut
arrêter les bêtises d'un abat sons sous
françois hollande
sous françois hollande mais même sous
nicolas sarkozy mais même cette manière
alors macron c'est différent parce que
parfois je dois reconnaître parfois il a
quelques intuitions depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir sur ces questions là on parlait
de renseignements économiques par
exemple
quelques lucidité je sais pas en
finlande us voilà des éclairs de
lucidité ou
et donc mais
oui enfin mais mais mais en tout cas
sous françois hollande s'était laissé
faire total c'est fait c'est françois
qui qu'il sait tout faire avec eux
sur les haies sur l'exemple d'airbus sur
l'exemple d'airbus pas ce qui est très
clair c'est qu'il ya plein de gens dans
la communauté du renseignement qui ont
alerté sur le fait que le grand patron
d'airbus à l'époque enders avait donc
ouvert les livres on va dire de compte
c'est surtout de
conduire avait permis un cabinet
d'avocats américain de mener l enquête
au coeur même du groupe avec des en
récupérant
les tous les contacts des commerciaux du
groupe au niveau international en
permettant aux avocats et également à
des cabinets de conseils justement
américains quasiment tous deux
interviewé très durement les différents
cadres d'airbus à l'époque donc là on
est totalement dans une faille de
sécurité de mon point de vue majeur même
si du côté d'airbus le management que
j'avais interviewé à l'époque m'avait
dit tout est sous le contrôle de la dgsi
oui bien sûr
non mais c'est sûr et donc françois
hollande et michel sapin son ministre
des finances quand je les ai interrogés
sur ce dossier là
tous les deux expliqué il ya un enjeu de
corruption la justice va pas c
est donc en fait il n'est pas du tout la
prise en considération des enjeux
stratégiques derrière des questions de
de déperdition de connaissances et
surtout de de transfert de là pour le
coup de d'information puisque en gros
les américains ont récupéré tout le
réseau commercial
d'airbus notamment dans la défense
là où ça posait beaucoup de problèmes
c'est que ce réseau commercial
étaient partagés souvent avec d'autres
entreprises de défense et d'armement
français donc thales et dassault en tête
mbd a aussi les missiles mais évidemment
groupe européen même s'il n'est pas
entendu ils sont en train d'y dire si
mal à savoir enfin c'est oui
il ya un petit un petit souci là puis
après c'est toute l'arborescence moment
bref en tout cas
hollande et sapins
quand je les ai interpellé sur ce sujet
là il se réfugiait nom en gros il ya un
souci de corruption on sort les
parapluies et voilà
c'était assez étonnant parce que de
l'autre côté moi jamais j'avais mes
contacts et mes sources du côté d'airbus
qui ou de l'environnement autour
d'airbus qui qui était juste scandalisé
de ce qui se passait c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'ils sont c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
venus vers moi entre autres quelles sont
venus vers moi et
on est là pour le coup on ressent le
contient un sentiment d'impuissance
total
les plus hautes autorités de l'état ont
l'air totalement
démunis un peu comme sous l'une
soviétique peut-être
genre sous tchernobyl la série las sur
l'accident de tchernobyl le montre bien
d'ailleurs comment les comment les plus
hautes autorités du nom soviétique à
l'époque en ligne ou tchernobyl était
dans une forme de déni de ce qui était
en train de se dérouler quoi et je
trouve que sur ces sujets là on est
encore encore la prise de conscience et
comment ça quand même monté mais on est
quand même encore pas mal sur le déni
et je reviens donc à
au câble sous marin enfin si vous voulez
les câbles sous marins l'autre élément
très intéressant
c'est que la france de par sa position
géographique l'hexagone est le prince un
des principaux points d'entrée de ces
câbles sous-marins au niveau
international c'est à dire que on est je
vais prendre un image aéroportuaire on
est le 1 br
de l'internet mondial par ces câbles
sous-marins
câble sous-marin d'ailleurs qui sont de
plus en plus privatisé par les young à
femmes dis donc google facebook
alors ça s'appelle mais tu as maintenant
mais enfin tous ces groupes là
d'ailleurs
on une intégration verticale aujourd'hui
y compris jusqu'aux activités
industrielles ils développent leur
propre câble sous marin pour contourner
d'ailleurs les états
mais beaucoup de câbles se branche en
france donc des câbles transatlantiques
qui se branche sur la sur la façade
atlantique française et surtout le fric
beaucoup de câbles qui partent de
marseille et de la camargue qui part sur
l'afrique parts sur l'asie le
moyen-orient est donc en fait on est un
site totalement stratégique d'ailleurs
edouard snowdon je l'avais dit en 2013
parce qu'il avait dévoilé
cet élément là mais ça n'avait été que
finalement peu relayé en france
parce qu'il avait dévoilé le site
stratégique notamment de la camargue sur
un câble et je sais plus exactement ce
qu'il avait dévoilé dans le détail là
j'aime ma mémoire me fait défaut mais
reste que en fait il ya de plus en plus
de câble d'ailleurs qui se branche du
côté de marseille puisqu'il ya aussi les
chinois qui branche des câbles du côté
de marseille et l'autre découverte c'est
que les américains alors ça je ne sais
pas si c'est par manque d'investissement
ou par impossibilité technique
parce que c'est quand même très long les
distances là n'ont pas d'accès direct à
l'afrique
au niveau des câbles sous marins c'est à
dire qu'ils sont obligés de se brancher
sur les câbles sous-marins qui passe par
la france pour pouvoir espionner et le
continent africain
et ça c'est un élément très important
pour revenir à l'impuissance ou
l'impossibilité des services français
des heures en termes de renseignements
économiques d'avoir des opérations
offensives à l'égard de nos alliés
américains c'est qu'en fait depuis très
longtemps la dgse et la msa ont des
accords secrets ça m'a été confirmé aux
médias à demi mots ou par quelques
silences par quelques regards entendus
par certains hauts responsables ou
ancien responsable du renseignement
français
voilà
quand on voit que les américains ont
quelques capacités de branchement furent
interdites ou vigilant et
on détourne le regard dans ce qu logique
dans ce que j'ai compris
et ça va très loin cette question des
câbles sous main
parce que comme on l'a dit les ports
sont des lieux stratégiques pas
uniquement pour le commerce mondial mais
aussi par rapport à ses capacités de
découpe sur ces câbles sous marins pour
les services de renseignement du monde
entier enfin notamment la nasa est en
fête
alors ça c'est toute une partie de l'anc
est que je fais sur le groupe bolloré
alors là plusieurs choses
c'est l'arborescence
c'est que j'ai découvert un que la
guerre bolloré elysées
prend sa source en afrique et sur les
activités africaines de bolloré
pourquoi parce que le groupe msc
qui a un groupe qui est un art match le
plus gros qui est devenu le plus gros
armateur mondial
et qui a aussi une activité de gestion
de porc en intégration verticale et
logistiques donc groupe italo suisse
basée à genève
après on pourra parler de ce qu'elle est
mais c'est réellement mais ce groupe là
non comme chacun sait peut-être en tout
cas la famille propriétaire des mets
c'est la famille à ponte et de la
famille d'alexis colère le secrétaire
général de l'elysée donc c'est ce que
mediapart a appelé la sphère colère avec
en pointant les éventuels conflits
d'intérêts caractérisée du haut
fonctionnaire
alexis colère qui dans ses différentes
fonctions à bercy temps l ape que comme
administrateur de l'état aux chantiers
navals de saint nazaire que comme
directeur adjoint de cabinet de pierre
moscovici directeur de cabinet de
emmanuel macron est désormais secrétaire
général de l'elysée il ya de forts
doutes et la justice enquête sur ça je
suis un vrai des ports formalisé dès
qu'il s'agissait de transport portuaire
de financement par l'état des paquebots
msc parce qu'elle est mais c'est le
principe du sud ou souvenirs voit la
présomption d'innocence bien évidemment
l'enquète est très longue et la justice
est très lente sur le sujet
malgré les révélations de mediapart moi
je vais plus loin dans le livre sur
certains aspects du dossier sur plan
juridique mais surtout
je montre qu' il y a des formes vraiment
d'effort lien entre alexis coller à la
famille à ponte sa foot non non non mais
très clairement
le depor si des porcs il y a eu est
particulièrement informel oh là là
est
bon tout ça est racontée dans le livre
d'une manière un peu plus direct bien
évidemment mais restons prudents et
et
en fait vincent bolloré et le groupe
bolloré considère que
les services de l'état que l'elysée ne
l'a pas suffisamment soutenue dans ses
activités africaines et logistique
depuis le début du quinquennat
qu'un kebab accros du quinquennat macron
est alors l'aurait alors qu'elle protège
les câbles le port infra structures
ainsi de suite alors on va y venir mais
alors que bolloré considère est
considéré ainsi que beaucoup d'initiés
de la françafrique est habitué de la
françafrique considéré qu en gros le
groupe bolloré groupe privé et
défendent est aussi les internationaux
français donc il y en ait dans une
troupe patriotique il fallait donc on
est dans une sorte aussi la de zones
grises
et de facilités de langage et logistique
mais c'est vrai que nicolas sarkozy mais
également françois hollande on l'a
oublié parce que c'est un peu facile
aujourd'hui de dire que bolloré c'est
uniquement zemmour mais le parti
socialiste français a été très proche de
vincent bolloré durant le quinquennat de
françois hollande
même si françois hollande la toute fin
de son quinquennat expliqué qu'il
fallait pas faire confiance à vincent
bolloré parce que c'est un catholique
intégriste mais en réalité les
socialistes et françois hollande n'ont
eu rien à redire quand bolloré a pris le
contrôle de canal+ ainsi que le prix le
contrôle du groupe vivendi donc bon ça
je le rappelle dans le livre mais c'est
quand même important de le rappeler les
catholiques les personnes dit qu'il est
aux terroristes c'est plus partie
saucisses qui lui disait enfin il est
quand même bien catholique ça c'est une
évidence mais c'est françois hollande
qui déclarait ça auprès de mes confrères
et notamment de mon souvenir d'un livre
alors pas de pattes d'havas et l'homme
mais dans un livre coécrit par quand je
crois karim rissouli de france 5
publié en août 2016 il a raison ils ont
recueilli une confidence d'hollande qui
explique voilà vincent bolloré il faut
pas faire confiance en vincent bolloré
alors qu'il a fait tout le contraire
durant le quinquennat mais non c'est pas
grave
notamment parce que c'est 1,5 à taux
très catho très conservateur ce qui
était le point de vue d'ailleurs d'un
proche de françois hollande qui est
l'avocat jean pierre mignard mais bon
passons ces parenthèses dans parenthèse
je reviens à bolloré dont bolloré de ce
manière considère comme un dû que l'état
français le soutiennent en afrique et
que l'elysée le soutiennent en afrique
je rappelle d'ailleurs que le groupe
bolloré historiquement en afrique à
récupérer les activités du groupe rivaux
le groupe rivaux
on va dire c'est un patrimoine français
du colonialisme français
parce que c'est un groupe qui avait des
plantations en afrique de l'ouest mais
également en asie en indonésie en
indochine c'est un groupe surpuissant à
l'époque
qui a survécu à la décolonisation
donc on est dans le néo colonies ce
monde veut dire
assis sur un tas d'or plein de plein de
petites caisses partout
opacité très importantes et le groupe
rivaux c'était du bon pied c'est vrai ça
c'est documenté perdre enquête
journalistique l'ont expliqué biographie
de vincent bolloré la fin à 90 de renaud
lecadre journaliste à libération et de
je ne sais plus qu'ils étaient deux sur
le coup
j'oublie le nom de la consoeur je suis
désolé et
ils tous lui parlait de bien sûr du
groupe rivaux et
donc le groupe rivaux s'étaient aussi la
banque rivaud le manque rivaux qui a
longtemps financé en fait la droite
française
voilà ça c'est pour le passé que fait
des crédits ben on était dans une
période où et on était dans une période
où les règles du financement de la vie
publique qui est partie solide et est
plus souple voile a été plus rude
pour la petite anecdote au début des
années 90 la banque rivaud a fait
l'objet d'un raid de force économique
proche du parti socialiste mitterrand a
essayé de récupérer la banque rivaud bon
finalement ça s'est terminé
après le gouvernement balladur notamment
avec la prise de contrôle par vincent
bolloré du groupe rivaux pour c'est là
où il est devenu très très puissant à ce
moment là et c'est là où il a pu
développer à partir des années 2000 son
groupe sur les terrains africains
notamment logistiques et encore au delà
même de des trésors de guerre sur les
plantations là il ya un haut cadre un
ancien haut cadre de bolloré qui
s'appelle dominique lafont qui m'a parlé
non dans le cadre de l' enquête en bonne
et qui m'a fait le bilan de toute son
activité parce que c'était le monsieur
afrique de bolloré entre 2010 et 2014
et c'est lui qui a développé notamment
la stratégie de concessions portuaires
du groupe bolloré car un sport
jeune aussi léger sous
on peut se poser la question parce que
donc en fait ce qu'on m'a non pour
accélérer dans le récit
donc je disais
que vincent bolloré considéré qu'il
n'était pas soutenu par l'elysée sous la
période macron ça a été un peu sa
mauvaise surprise parce qu'il avait mis
quelques pions et quelques acteurs de
son influence notamment le groupe havas
auprès du candidat macron là aussi on le
rappelle assez peu et en 2018 en fait
dès l'automne 2010 est ce à ce temps
très fortement en coulisses en 2018 ya
les fameuses mises en examen
spectaculaire de vincent bolloré après
des gardes à vues spectaculaires a elle
aussi
est là vincent bolloré
fait qu'on a fait une tribune dans le
jdd
ainsi qu'un courrier aux salariés très
alarmiste en disant si l'état ne nous
aide pas
on se sera les chinois qui vont
récupérer nos activités donc là il fait
un peu
posture victimaire il fait un peu du
chantage au pouvoir publier un peu
pouvoirs publics français où c'est la
réalité aussi d'ailleurs il avait
d'ailleurs commencé à collaborer à
collaborer avec les chinois mais c'est
aussi des cartes postales genre je
commence à collaborer avec le chinois
donc voilà et en fait il fait état dans
ce courrier ça c'est très intéressant
dans jeu surpuissant et c'est ce qu'il
dit c'est ce qu'il dit dans courrier aux
salariés dans mon souvenir
parce que illicites je crois un ancien
haut cadre de bolloré qui est connu
maintenant comme le loup blanc comme
l'ennemi historique de vincent bolloré
pour les journalistes enquêtent sur la
place de paris qui est jacques
dupuydauby
qui s'est fâché avec bolloré enfin bref
je passe les détails mais en fait dans
le courrier il dit il ya des enjeux
surpuissant je sais plus si c'est
exactement le terme est en tout cas très
puissant un autre rencontre est en fait
en deux qui donnent aux frais de vincent
bolloré et du groupe bolloré et
notamment en afrique
en 2019 de totalement se comprendre oui
non mais moi je sais pas que enfin sais
pas j'ai pas fait une enquête contre
pour j'analyse voilages analyse et
j'enquête
la complexité des choses justement je
fais pas de morale un jeu je raconte aux
journalistes
je rate dans un sens comme dans un autre
que ce soit de la gauche la droite tout
le monde est dans l'invectivé tout le
monde dans la morale finalement donc je
reviens parce que j'essaye de raconter
des conneries que j'ai découvert c'est
que donc il se sent menacé et vincent
bolloré le groupe bolloré se sont
menacés à l'époque
jusqu'à dire publiquement qu'il ya des
enjeux très puissant face à lui il les
qualifie pas et en fait
mes lecteurs s'ils trouvent un intérêt à
se procurer le livre mon livre
découvriront en fait différents
interlocuteurs qui ont pu me parler
entre nous qui menons pu faire des
confidences à l'époque sur le fait qu'
une partie des ennemis de vincent
bolloré était constituée par le groupe
est massée dans la famille propriétaire
et gérante et de la famille d'alexis
colère c'est pas de sa faute non
safavide on choisit pas sa famille mais
quand on est au plus haut niveau de
l'état il peut y avoir quelques
interférences on va dire ça comme ça et
d'ailleurs il ya un épisode suit ce
fameux printemps 2010 huit
printemps 2018 il s'est passé beaucoup
de choses enfin en 2018 pour la macro ni
on arrive à l'automne 2010 8 début 2019
non un peu plus après mes cours en 2019
coup de tonnerre pour le groupe bolloré
y perdent la concession du port de
douala cameroun
qui est d'ailleurs une concession
stratégique parce que le port de douala
permet de le ravitaillement entre
guillemets le ravitaillement mais du
tchad et la centrafrique
donc là aussi on est sur des intérêts
français est très important et à force
marc khanne il ya l'armée tchadienne
donc il ya des implications là on va
dire de l'influencé française en afrique
considérable
et d'ailleurs par le passé c'est à dire
sous françois hollande françois hollande
et jean yves le drian
s'était démené pour préserver la
concession du port de douala
dans les mains de vincent bolloré la
coup de tonnerre la concession du port
de douala est confiée par le
gouvernement ait le pouvoir camerounais
à la filiale t-il la filiale de gestion
de porcs du groupe msc
moi je me souviens très bien parce que à
l'époque je commençais à m'interroger on
va dire sur ce qu'était m à c alors je
peux faire une variété du diable
cc c'est un coup de pas de bol il change
de concession il change de l'entreprise
et c'est le business c'est le business
non mais les normales tout à fait mais
là je me place du point de vue de
vincent bolloré tels que ça a été vécue
à ma connaissance au sein du groupe
bolloré cers a été vécue comme une
agression inacceptable
fausto 6 compris oui enfin deux dents si
on reste dans sa tête si l'on raisonne
sur you tic enfin si on raisonne non
parce que attention pas que patriotique
parce que c'est bernard squarcini qui va
dire ça mais ancien patron des
renseignements intérieurs
bonjour donc voilà mai
non si on se place dans l'idée que
vincent bolloré se fait de lui-même
qui peut se comprendre mais vincent
bolloré en afrique a le rang de chef
d'état africain enfin deux chefs d'état
voilà c'est quand il se déplaçait en
tout cas il ya quelques années sa
puissance est telle que
que voilà il avait eu un poids
diplomatique d'ailleurs pour parler des
diplomates français il ya quelqu'un qui
m'a fait une confidence quand le vincent
bolloré à une concession ou des
activités dans un pays ça créé une forme
d'inertie dans les rapports de l'état
français avec l'état en question
voilà c'était le terme qui m'a été
employée par le diplomate inertie ça
passe
ça passe par différents canaux mais
vraisemblablement ça rend les choses à
la fois peut-être plus facile sur
certains aspects les plus sensibles en
tout cas du point de vue d'un diplomate
d'ailleurs qui ne pèse plus grands et
qu'ils ne pèsent plus grand chose et
donc
il faut savoir d'ailleurs que le groupe
bolloré ces dernières années assurait la
logistique
à venir pas forcément militaire mais
enfin une partie de la logistique de
l'opération barkan le groupe bolloré
avait un contrat de logistique avec
l'armée française
contrat qui a été cassée il ya quelques
mois je sais pas s'il a été renouvelée
ça j'ai pas vérifié en tout cas de
mémoire il avait un contrat et donc je
reviens à la perte de la concession du
port de douala depuis il ya eu un
contentieux juridique qui fait que ms et
bolloré se sont trouvés
neutralisées sur le port de douala si
parce que l'état camerounais a en partie
nationalisé le port de douala
les deux groupes sont en voie d d'esker
juridiques et des recours dans tous les
sens et donc en fait pour l'instant
c'est là enfin c'est pas une armistice
parce que mais du coup c'est plutôt le
statu quo même si finalement à ma
connaissance
le groupe bolloré a plutôt marqué des
points sur plan juridique mais en fait
comme ils sont toujours en contentieux
s'est laissée par le port de douala a
échappé on va dire au contrôle du groupe
bolloré mais au delà du port de dollars
dans l' enquête que j'ai menée il ya
tout un tas d'autres acteurs qu'on était
là pour le coup qui ont reçu le soutien
de l'état français notamment par la
caisse des dépôts
par d'autres acteurs
dont certains étaient pas forcément
d'ailleurs franco-française ses acteurs
et qui ont pu aussi marquer leurs petits
drapeaux dans certains pays historique
de la françafrique comme le gabon
ça je raconte ça en détail est où là par
exemple donc il ya un groupe qui
s'appellera skis qui a carrément
construire un port en eau profonde au
gabon
sans avoir encore le contrat ou la
permission et tout ça à côté d'eux des
activités de porc de bolloré donc là ça
commence à faire beaucoup
tout ça dans l'inscription d'un terrain
africain où le jeu des superpuissances
qu'on décrivait au début de la
discussion au jeu des hyper puissance
mais également des puissances
intermédiaires donc je peux évoquer la
turquie la russie israël
qui sont importants dans le jeu parce
que très efficace avec leurs
spécificités spécificités qu'on aime
respectives
et bien
les difficultés du groupe bolloré ont
parlé de la chine et ailiers sont liés
ces difficultés sont liées à ces jeux de
super puissance et de puissance
aujourd'hui depuis les difficultés du
groupe bolloré
s'est en fait les balles perdues des
difficultés que la france rencontre en
afrique c'est à dire qu'on est en train
de se fermer je vais être vulgaire je
suis désolé on est en train de se faire
botter le cul
par la chine la russie les états unis
parce que on se retrouve avec des
diplomates
par les états unis sur l'afrique ils ont
toujours leurs billets à 500 qui se
baladent en fin de mon point de vue ils
sont ils se sont fait dépasser
en tout cas ils se sont faits oui ils
sont inquiets par la présence de la
chine en afrique
la question des métaux rares extrêmement
importante qu'on n'a pas encore évoqué
notamment auraient pu mener moratti du
congo mais dans d'autres états africains
donc les questions minières qui sont
aujourd'hui crucial et notamment crucial
parce qu'en fait c'est le ça fait partie
de ce basculement du monde donc deux
soeurs de la transition écologique
troicki dépôt transition
en tout cas de
matériaux totalement nécessaire aux
smartphones aux outils technologiques au
hardware à tout ça enfin tout ce qui ce
qui fait le monde numérique
d'aujourd'hui est en fait on assiste à
un basculement parce que dans le cadre
géopolitique mondiale jusqu'à présent on
va dire le
lalala donné à avoir en compte que
c'était à prendre en compte c'était le
pétrole principalement ela il ya deux
changements majeurs
c'est que les états unis sont devenus en
partie autonome grâce au gaz de schiste
et au pétrole de schiste même s'il faut
que le baril de pétrole soit au dessus
de 55 $ je crois en tout cas
quand c'est le cas
c'est tout bénef pour les états unis
c'est pour ça qu'ils se sont désengagés
d'ailleurs du moyen-orient petit à petit
sur plan stratégique
et donc en fait là vous une des vraies
raisons du choc entre la chine et la
nuit d'un point de vue industriel
technologique et
stratégique
c'est d'ailleurs ces métaux rares alors
ça a été décrit très bien par guillaume
pitron
café un livre formidable qui s'appelle
la guerre des métaux rares que je cite
d'ailleurs non livre et je parle assez
peu des métaux rares parce que comme il
suffit qu'il avait fait tout ce livre
mais j'évoque qui est vaguement la
question des métaux rares et si je
reviens à la question des
superpuissances où des puissances tout
court régional extérieur en tout cas au
continent africain la question des
métaux rares est importante et les etats
unis se sont fait quand même fait quoi
finalement on connaît ça c'est mal
l'afrique en réalité
ap à certains endroits et surtout ils
ont utilisé de mon point de vue ces
dernières années ils ont souvent utilisé
la turquie
parce que les américains sont dans une
stratégie d' influence régionale au
moyen-orient comme en afrique par par
proxy par procuration et donc qui passe
par des intermédiaires et donc des
alliés intermédiaires et donc en
l'occurrence la turquie ce qui est très
intéressant parce que en fait ça éclaire
sous un jour nouveau aussi les guerres
de langage très dur qui a pu avoir entre
emmanuel macron et r doan et
parce qu'en fait quand emmanuel macron
s'attaquèrent douanes et vice et versa
il fallait jamais oublier que derrière
les turcs y avait les américains donc
oui certes on parle beaucoup des russes
en afrique et avec wagner maintenant le
mali le centrafrique du fait d'ailleurs
de nombreuses erreurs tactiques du côté
du camp français et notamment du fait
que emmanuel macron a décidé de
maintenir le fils débit après la mort de
déby au tchad qui a été une sorte de
catastrophe face à cette manière parce
que ça a été plutôt mal perçu la raison
par à la fois les sociétés civiles
africaines et par les dirigeants
africains parce qu'en réalité la france
a décidé de privilégier le lien du sang
enfin d'ailleurs le fils débit etc plus
c'est compliqué l'histoire met enfin en
tout cas de le lien de la famille plus
que du delà des institutions de chad yen
même si le chat n'est pas une démocratie
puisse dire
reste que ça ça peut expliquer le jeu de
dominos qui se déroule aujourd'hui en
afrique notamment au mali et donc
bien évidemment que la france a commis
énormément d'erreurs mais la france la
france cette diplomate oui les
dirigeants les dirigeants français on va
dire les nuages en français ce que même
les diplomates justement ça c'était en
tout cas un diplomate qui connaît bien
l'afrique qui m'avait parlé de ça me
disais que les diplomates justement pour
revenir au début de la discussion
s'était fait totalement dépassés en
termes d' analyse stratégique sur
l'afrique ses nerfs en cours en gros
aujourd'hui que ce soit par rapport on
va dire pour conséquence de l'opération
marque anne mais en gros c'est la dgse
et les militaires qui ont le dernier mot
sur notre stratégie en tout cas ces
dernières années en afrique donc ça ça
permet pas de développer des relations
apaisées et relativement égalitaire que
ce soit tant avec les dirigeants
africains qu'avec les sociétés civiles
africaines je dis ça au passage
d'ailleurs j'en discutais avec un
journaliste franco camerounais
il ya quelques temps
monsieur du média qui me disait que je
me disais qu'il ne comprenait pas en
ayant les deux cultures que la france
jouait pas la stratégie du soft power et
notamment de relations apaisées
alors qu'il ya plein de choses et
notamment l'accueil des étudiants
étrangers il ya plein de choses et
aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas dis depuis le début de
l'entretien mais on parlait
au départ de l'extrême droite
qui sort sur l'extrême française qui
sortent sur la nostalgie
souveraine y voit là où et puis eric
zemmour qui parle du grand déclassement
industriel alors je suis désolé mais
eric zemmour en fait nan ses comptes
enfin il se contrefiche est de delà de
l'industrie et des industries depuis
bien longtemps en réalité c'est bien
uniquement parce qu'il a pris le costume
de candidat à l'élection présidentielle
qui parlent tous d'un coup d'industrie
d'ailleurs mon petit doigt me dit que
l'un de ses conseillers informels loïk
le floch prigent et qui est donc
anciennes figures industriel soul de la
mitterrandie
mêmes lui-même frustré parce qu il a dit
à mes contacts c'est des propos
rapportés il a dit à mes contacts au
moins mitterrand m'écoutait ce qui n'est
pas le cas de eric zemmour bon je laisse
ça c'était juste pour l'anecdote
il ça c'est un problème parce que
l'extrême droite
zemmour le pen et même l'ensemble du
spectre politique on est obnubilé dans
le débat public français par les
questions identitaires par laquelle on
est obnubilé par la question du repli
comme on a peur de tout de toutes les
différences de tout de l'étranger
et résultat on parle pas des vrais
sujets ce qu'on a évoqué depuis là je
sais pas à 2 heures peut-être des mois
noir mais en tout cas de guerre car
aucune heure quarante
et c'est ça le fond de la faire sur le
plan démocratique ce coup là le et
pourquoi mais pourquoi on les évoque pas
au delà même de la question extrêmement
parce que en fait l'extrême droite est
largement instrumentalisée par les
autres
que ce soit macron par les autres forces
politiques je passe a été longtemps le
parti socialiste est un il comprit la
droite républicaine a joué aussi jeu là
moi je le vois parce qu'en tant que
journaliste parfois je fais des
interviews de responsables politiques
notamment la tribune sur les questions
économiques stratégiques géostratégique
je leur pose des questions sur ce qu'il
pensait oui mais déjà ces voix là ils
sont pas très fort mais pas très
compétent généralement alors des fois il
ya des surprises d'ailleurs il y en a
dans les candidats quelques personnes
qui se sont formées en même y compris
encore récemment mais mais mais mais
globalement
ils ont ils ont ils fui ces questions là
la plupart du temps c'est difficile
quand on peut plus sculpté du vent et
brasser de l'air chaud voilà voilà il
faut prendre la main dans le pot de
confiture de leur ignorance sur des
sujets clés
donc mon plage fait j'ai fait mon petit
laïus de gauche mais enfin tout cas
qui concerne d'ailleurs aussi la gauche
ce qu'il en reste mais enfin en tout cas
en tout cas il ya un problème c'est on
ne peut pas continuer à parler de même
là pour le coup de climat dans une sorte
d terre ou de parler de souveraineté
économique comme on l'a dit sans parler
concrètement les vrais sujets alors
qu'on parle eux ont fuit juste une
parenthèse entre nous parce que le
bouquin il fait 6 ans jusqu'aux clair
ajoute juste un truc centrale mon âme
tout aux yeux quand il a évoqué
sur bolloré l'afrique est massé oui
voilà
l'une des explications qui m'a été
d'aider transmises par des proches de
vincent bolloré en l'occurrence
c'est effectivement l'enjeu des câbles
sous marins et la france avaient tout
intérêt à sauver le soldat boulangerie
pour l'histoire de câbles sous marins
je ne sais pas joker du cul un
joker mais gros c'est ça ouais ouais
ouais c'est écrit dans le livre et c'est
écrit dans le livre c'est
22 euros 50 ben
oui oui c'est ses bas vous lirez je vais
pas tout raconter mais pas de vous
raconter quand même pas dire gg raconté
assez peu de ce que j'écris là c'est ça
qui est bien c'est parce que gbagbo
devait ses danses
ça se lit bien ça se tient bien dans la
main c'est bien écrit il ya plein de
petites anecdotes avec des ramifications
à gauche à droite is des classes quand
même pour l interviewer y va sur le
terrain
mais je n'aime pas ça au téléphone oui
ça c'est bien ça fort heureusement
revenons à nos moutons vous qui êtes
journaliste d'investigation vous qu'ils
avaient creusé les enquêtes
qui avait creusé la géopolitique les
questions stratégie d'énergie de
renseignement d'accès à l'information
bon entre vous et moi un et et les 930
me le voler
on est un petit peu
dans la dans la panade là non on a une
élite mais pas formé une campagne
présidentielle qui ne s'attardent que l
écume des choses
on a nos institutions qui sont déroulées
par des cabinets privés qui sont entrain
dubé risée totalement non fonctionnaires
censés être les garants de notre
savoir-faire de notre intégrité et j'en
passe la france elle va où là la france
elle va se faire tirer 10 et on vit en
fait sur les restes de nous de nos
conquêtes précédente de nos colonies
alors voilà on a en a créé d'autres
technologiques notre pointe de diamant
technologie grâce à nos colonies alors
là qu'une colonie on se fait botter
passez moi l'expression mais on se fait
botter le cul d'afrique parce que les
africains soient ya des copains qui
souhait mieux ou qui payent mieux où ils
ont plus envie de nous voir ça c'est le
jeu puis on n'a pas entretenu
correctement d'ailleurs n'en est donc on
va se retrouver nous sur notre petit
hexagone
avec une technologie qui part en chine
qui se fait absorber par les états unis
qu'ils parlent française qui n'ait pu
écouter et notre élite en fait qui qui
brasse de l'air chaud qui va se
reconfigurer qui va se recycler dans le
privé
on va où mark alors déjà je suis pas sûr
que l'élite parce que je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire l'élite enfin je sais mais
globalisé comme ça c'est écrivez-moi au
tibet on les voit partir de ce niveau là
mais
non il ya plein de gens qui sont hyper
formés
mais malheureusement de mon point de vue
ils sont pas engagés dans la sphère
publique et dans le débat politique
c'est tout le paradoxe d'ailleurs du
maquereau nice mais de la disruption ma
chronique comme on dit c'est que
on assiste à la destruction des quelques
fermes dans la foi de contre-pouvoir
institutionnels et de lieux de vie
démocratique
qui étaient les partis politiques quoi
qu'on pense des partis politiques c'est
à dire que ça re ça revient à la phrase
de d'exergue du livre
c'est pas parce que donc quand il ya le
monde qui se détruit si on crée rien à
côté eh ben c'est la catastrophe et donc
là
nous mon point de vue ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que
il ya tout un pan d'organisation
politique qui a trait passer au delà
même des questions institutionnelles
liées à la vème république pourquoi et
pour tous mais ça a trépassé parce que
on parlait la libéralisation mais c'est
parce que les responsables politiques
eux-mêmes de tous bords sont totalement
hubert ise en fait c'est tellement c'est
tellement plus facile jour le plus long
hmm hmm mélenchon du point de vue que je
voulais montrer qu est ce que je voulais
dire par hub et reese est le jouet dire
que
voilà quand tous les spécialistes de
sciences po et de la démocratie parle du
populisme en fait le populisme c'est
quoi c'est enfin qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'air d'agen c'est c'est en tout cas
c'est l'idée d'un homme une femme
présidentielle en contact direct avec
les français forcément avec les réseaux
sociaux ils peuvent avoir ça et d'une
certaine manière c'est très bien que
grâce aux réseaux sociaux sacré de la
démocratie mais dans le même temps ça
sur les réseaux sociaux entre guillemets
la mobilisation par les réseaux sociaux
et on l'a vu avec les gilet jaune ne
suffisent pas à créer de l' expertise et
du collectif d'une certaine manière
alors sacré du collectif de lutte de
luttes sociales mais sacré pas forcément
du collectif d'intelligence collective
et les partis politiques
n'avait quasiment plus à en leur sein
depuis 20 ans il faut pas se leurrer
c'était devenu plus que ça ce n'était
que des devenus des ddd des institutions
pour conquérir le pouvoir à tout prix
il ya qu'à voir l'évolution du parti
socialiste depuis 30 ans mais mais cette
les partis politiques c'étaient les sas
qui permettait la prise de contrôle de
l'état aussi mais la prise de contrôle
de l'état d'un point de vue de politique
publique donc maintenant on se plaint à
raison des cabinets privés du management
public comme on dit qui en fait
l'utilisation d'outils de grandes firmes
internationales et transnationale des
solutions mais sur l'état mais c'est pas
comme ça qu'un état et à une vie
démocratique devrait réellement être
organisé donc je plaide pas forcément
pour le retour des vieux partis
politiques traditionnels il faut juste
être quand même conscient que quand on
ne forme pas des espaces collectifs de
discussion à tous niveaux
de transfert d'information ça peut poser
un problème proprement stratégique la
dernière fois que j'étais venu je parle
j'ai parlé beaucoup de médias et du
journalisme
tous les sujets stratégiques là qu'on a
évoqué aujourd'hui dans le champ de
l'information en france
dont déjà l'information ça demande un
coup ça demande un effort mais justement
les les gens là qui conte à qui on
envoie des mails pour parler des gens
importants
ils sont ils sont abonnés des lettres
confidentielles
ils utilisent ils coûtent un bras ils
utilisent des cabines est dit
d'intelligence économique coûte au moins
qui coûte un bras mais y est notamment
dans le monde de la finance par exemple
c'est c'est un des avantages enfin de
luxe est acquis c'est celui qui aura
l'information le premier pour spéculer
donc ces gens là ils sont ultra
connectés ultra informés et y compris et
ils sont parfois ultra informé de
d'éléments hyper stratégique sur tout un
tas de sujets le problème démocratique
qui se pose aujourd'hui est d'ailleurs
lié aussi à l'hyper concentration dans
les médias l'oligarchie dation vincent
bolloré gerra jette tout le monde mais
également d'autres grands oligarques qui
rachète une bonne partie de la presse
c'est qu'on va plutôt faire du hanouna
que de présenter les vrais enjeux
stratégiques auprès de la population la
plus large donc moi quand je fais des
livres on dit amassé complexe quand même
c'est pas très sexy c'est compliqué
mais pourtant c'est des informations qui
devraient être davantage mise au premier
plan parce que là je vais je vais citer
je ne sais plus qui
mais d'ailleurs très connu
mais
le problème c'est que sacré
sacré des chapes de plomb ce système
sacré du mensonge par omission
et donc après sacré du complotisme entre
guillemets enfin ce qu'on appelle
complotisme sacré du fantasque en fait
les gens qui sont en recherche
d'explications la plupart du temps sans
parce que vous parlez du côté par dont
on va parler du côté ils sont tous entre
eux dans un voyou fermés dont d'être
confidentielles c'est à dire que
pourquoi ça pose un problème informe
comme démocratique l'information c'est
que quand ce n'est qu'une partie de la
population qui disposent des
informations stratégiques le débat
démocratique est biaisé vu que ce n'est
pas les responsables politiques ou
certains d'entre eux ont parlé de
mélenchon parce que mélenchon
effectivement quoi qu'on en pense de lui
il y là une pédagogie
dans l'est dans les différents éléments
et sur les questions régaliennes il
s'est formé y compris encore depuis cinq
ans
mais là aussi qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
on le voit d'ailleurs tout le monde le
reconnaît
ils élèvent le niveau comme on dit alors
on dit que c'est un bonne arme bon
orateur mais il élève aussi le niveau
bon
mais au delà de la personne de mélenchon
il ya quand même une difficulté dans le
débat public
d'ouvrir les vrais débats
donc la semaine dernière quand le
président la république se déplace à
belfort pour faire son coup de com sur
les turbines arabe elle
il y a peu de voix autour pour créer du
débat pour dire pourquoi acheter des
turbines maintenant qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire à quel prix à quel coût
pourquoi edf
qu'est ce qu'on va faire après ce qu'on
va faire le père pas de lepers rien
déposé à ce que en finalement on laisse
tomber le nucléaire toutes ces questions
là elles ne sont elles sont même quand
elles sont posées les enjeux sont très
mal décrypter et c'est une
responsabilité qui est collective
voilà ça c'est
cm-cic c'est le sentiment c'est le
sentiment que j'ai et donc
moi ce qui m'a frappé après mon passage
le premier passage chez vous c'est que
vos habitués même plus qu'habitué mais
des gens qui regardent ces cures view
est ce qu'un vieux parfois caricaturé on
le sait mais les gens qui regardent
cette interview ils sont hyper formés
pour la plupart d'eux et d'entre eux
mêmes quand ils sont pas formés ils
s'intéressent ils sont autodidactes mais
ils font l'effort de s'informer mais
déjà pour regarder des interviews aussi
longue il faut prendre le temps le temps
c'est aussi de l'argent il faut il faut
se poser il faut réfléchir il faut
écouter quelqu'un déblatérer pendant
deux heures
qui glisse de lille y lisent les livres
y lisent les livres il se cultive
c'est ça ça s'appelle alors à gauche on
appelait ça éducation populaire
mais mais c'est tous et c'est tout se
sait tout ce travail là et donc pour
revenir à les élites sont pas formés ou
mal formés ça dépend de quel de quel
élite on parle
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de français
dans le monde économique dans les pme de
même dans les grands groupes
internationaux qui eux sont confrontés
aux réalités du monde d'aujourd'hui
malheureusement y compris sous la
majorité actuelle en 2017 qui était soi
disant disruptive on ne peut pas dire
que la majorité de députés dans marche
comme de la plupart des députés
l'assemblée nationale en dehors de
certaines exceptions il ya toujours des
exceptions mais on ne peut pas dire que
ils ont même temps au niveau de leurs
fonctions de député développé une
expertise
pertinente sur certains sujets en tout
cas en dehors de quelques individualités
le ventre mou de l'assemblée nationale
n'a pas provoqué une expertise très
importante
aussi à leur décharge parce que c'est un
parlement godillot donc donc on en
revient à l'idée de tout à l'heure
indépendamment de la personne emmanuel
macron c'est pas avec un homme ou une
femme seul qu'on va pouvoir emmener le
pays c'est pas vrai ça ça c'est prendre
les gens pour des idiots donc là on est
dans un
ah on est dans un moment où on est dans
des logiques bonapartiste
historique on va dire où c'est la
logique de la 5e mais qui aboutit à la
fin c'est pour ça que je parlais de
crise de régime mais je pense que c'est
c'est un élément qu'il faut sur lequel
il faut débattre on peut pas on peut pas
dire bah c'est c'est le plus mauvais des
on n'a pas trouvé mieux donc on garde
dont la vème république et on voit bien
que ça ne fonctionne plus et ça
fonctionne plus parce que la 5ème
république totalement verticale dans un
monde qui est aussi
très globale et très horizontale donc il
ya une confrontation des deux logiques
et qui aboutit à plusieurs bugs on va
dire ça comme ça pas besoin qu'il était
pas la communauté sikhe review sera la
norme et la plaisanterie mais
quand on est un simple journaliste
comment on fait pour s'abonner ou d'être
confidentielles on se débrouille pour
avoir un copain qui vous l'a fait passer
des bruits pour rien et c'est toujours
du journalisme deux bouts de ficelle
parce que l'on vous donne pas le pognon
pour aller ailleurs enquêté non mais
vous êtes ingénieux comme on fait aussi
pour pénétrer certains cercles vous avez
une belle cravate avec un costume bien
taillé ou c'est votre belle gueule qui
vous feront plus facilement j'espère que
j'ai très peur que
non mais j'ai pas
non je fais pas beaucoup d'efforts là
dedans
pour les infiltrés donc on est un peu le
principe mais mais mais comment fait
pour les infiltrés
par la connaissance des dossiers
mais ça ça on en avait parlé la dernière
fois je crois mais je peux pour revenir
rapidement tout le temps en train on en
avait déjà un peu parlé mais mais
dans une enquête
est gelée vos interlocuteurs qui parle
encore nous en off vous font confiance
s'il voit que vous maîtrisez les codes
et les informations si vous arrivez la
bouche en coeur en disant hé monsieur
monsieur madame madame tombe raconte mon
histoire où je veux un scoop je vais un
scoop je veux bourget je veux manger
c'est pas gentil pour les confrères mais
bon donc c'est ça qui est bien
on ne peut pas travailler c'est dommage
parce que y en a beaucoup qui veulent
bouger comme un bon oui mais pour pour
avoir la confiance de source parfois de
haut niveau est source de haut niveau
c'est tout dire n'importe quoi parce que
les sources de haut niveau peuvent
s'auto intoxiqué entre elles peuvent
également être dans le complot dans le
complotisme avoir une malle informations
par exemple il ya un élément très
intéressant du livre on reviendra dessus
après
un truc que j'ai découvert même les les
acteurs et notamment franco français
peuvent fois avoir du mal à percevoir
donc même les gens soi disant dit
importants ou dit très informés sont
parfois mal informés
notamment parce que les cabinets
d'intelligence économique ils ont
plusieurs clients dont nous donc il ya
décrié il ya des conflits d'intérêts que
ils n'ont pas forcément ils n'ont pas
forcément de bonne source
et donc là dedans
la facilité de l'infiltration entre
guillemets c'est d'abord à la
connaissance des dossiers et le niveau
d'information mais c'est pareil j'allais
dire au niveau d'une enquête policière
ou d'un juge d'instruction
le juge d'instruction où le policier
dont la comparaison un peu hasardeuse je
ne suis que journaliste heureusement
mais il arrive à avancer dans la
constitution d'un dossier ou de la
compréhension d'un dossier quand ils ont
intégré la logique des acteurs ou pour
parler comme un sociologue ce que j'ai
eu une formation de sociologue quand les
acteurs sur lequel vous enquêtez vous
comprenez les luttes internes dans
lesquelles ils sont proprement eux
engagés c'est à dire qu'en tant que
journaliste quand j'aborde un sujet
j'essaie toujours de réfléchir
cette personne me parle pourquoi et où
est elle
dans le champ de pouvoir qui la concerne
quel est son intérêt mais surtout quel
est son point de vue dans la lutte qui
la concerne dans cet univers vous parler
du nucléaire tout à l'heure alors cette
personne il préfère du nucléaire
américain donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
m'ont dit cela l'autre personne nous d'y
aller de pair ne fonctionne pas parce
qu'en fait il veut du nucléaire chinois
voilà et donc c'est par cette
compréhension des luttes internes ces
milieux qui sont parfois très opaque
que je bâtis mais enquête et que par
ailleurs j'acquiers de la confiance de
certaines sources
la difficulté que j'ai c'est que je
travaille pour différents médias mais je
suis pas intégrer une rédaction installé
et donc je fais des enquêtes au long
cours souvent alors parfois il m'arrive
de sortir des informations de faire des
scoops
il ya beaucoup d'informations beaucoup
de coupes dans le livre
mais c'est pas forcément des scoops
rentable médiatiquement qui crée le buzz
il ya beaucoup de documents dévoilés
dans le livre
mais généralement
les gens qui font fuiter des documents
il préfère quand le journal ce qu'ils
ont en face d'eux reprennent le récit
autour
et la difficulté d'une enquête d'une
enquête d'initiative quand on dit on une
enquête au long cours c'est finalement
on comprend un peu les différents récits
et les cons les les concurrences
d'intérêt qui tout ce qui oui et puis
les délais les différences de récits et
d'intérêt et donc on peut analyser les
choses plus froidement on peut expliquer
un peu plus les coulisses on dévoile les
cartes de tout le monde en fait le jeu
de cartes mais
les gens n'ont pas forcément à ce
moment-là intérêts de à vous parler donc
tout ça c'est subtil c'est utile parce
que d'un autre côté ils sont
peu importe le type de source il
respecte l'effort que je fais de
compréhension
même si parfois je peux faire des armes
et de compréhension de leur univers ou
de compréhension des enjeux techniques
aussi de ces univers là et tout ça avec
un salaire de misère oui enfin ça va oui
mais enfin veut pas oui c'est pas
en face de moi j'ai des gens qui qui qui
qui ont un qui ont un mode mais je ne
veux pas dans la fascination mais mais
mais c'est pas dans là c'est pas c'est
pas facile d'aborder ces gens qui sont
disponibles à tout moment qu'ils
prennent des avions à tout le monde qui
vivent dans des palaces qui
sont dans une autre réalité qui est la
mienne mais je suis pogné dans la
fascination ni dans leur vie c'est juste
que je constate que
dans le quotidien c'est un peu plus
compliqué à
gérer tout simplement mais ça c'est
autre chose la passion l'emportent ont à
dire l autre à l souci du travail bien
fait l'enfant
c'est une belle pub 2
revenons à nos moutons donc là on n'a
fait que chez pitre
on va pas tout on va pas tout dire ce
qu'il a des trucs comme dans le livre
qui sont comme
ya du lourd voyez dehors il ya du lourd
et comment ça a été écrit par les autres
médias c'est trop compliqué ou des
choses comme ça c'était il ya des
articles en préparation
me dit-on dans certains médias donc
bajaj j'attends j'attends que mes
confrères me lisent et produisent des
articles
le seul constat que je peux faire là je
parle pas de la presse écrite qui
travaillent encore mais en tout cas je
n'ai eu aucune invitation de télé radio
publique
peu pourquoi
c'est un simple constat mais peut-être
que ça va se débloquer dans les
prochains jours mais je n'ai eu aucune
invitation télé radio publique aucune
invitation des grosses machines
médiatiques les access prime time
donc c'est à vous quotidiens 28 minutes
émissions pourtant où parfois on aborde
des sujets sérieux ou parfois on aborde
des sujets complexes mais bon je ne suis
qu'un simple aux journalistes donc là
j'aborde des sujets très très bas très
complexe que je vous fous plus bas oui
mais enfin il
ne s'est pas non non je vais pas parler
de lui mais il préfère inviter des au
diplôme des anciens hauts diplomates
parfois
voilà mais c'est le sait le jeu aussi
enfin je m'embarque dans une enquête
j'ai peu de temps après après après
avoir fait le dernier livre j'ai
rencontré voix j'avais déjà rencontré à
plusieurs reprises et on n'était pas
forcément d'accord sur des sujets est
loin de là mais j'avais rencontré pierre
péan
je connaissais et je l'avais déjà
rencontré à plusieurs reprises mon
pourrons-nous plus jeune frais
ancien journaliste de l'express du
canard enchaîné 70 spécialiste de
l'énergie au départ il a commencé par la
pierre perrin il tait spécialise
l'énergie et du pétrole du marché du
pétrole puisqu ils ont
un beau coup de pub à dents dans ses
mémoires enfin
autobiographie publiée à titre posthume
que j'ai lu d'ailleurs très intéressante
oui il a eu des menaces il explique même
qu'il a il a eu des bombinettes devant
chez lui
ça a pu aller loin les années 80 ça
rigolait parent notamment quand il s'est
attaqué à certains chefs d'état
africains dans les années 80
il explique d'ailleurs dans son auto
biographie posthume
il explique comment aux alentours de jeu
c'est + 45 ans 50 ans après une premier
premier livre il a il a hésité à arrêter
arrêter le métier
voilà
et donc quand je rencontre une dernière
fois pierre péan
dont trois semaines avant un mois un
mois trois semaines avant sa mort
il
il avait un côté d'une fin d'une extrême
gentillesse
et trous qui m'appelait il était venu
avec mon livre il m'avait dit qu'il faut
que tu me le dédicace bon et
il m'a dit une phrase en partant il m'a
dit toute façon quand tu t'attaques au
système tu es seul
et bien évidemment dans le livre que
j'ai fait là je m'attaque entre
guillemets au système sert je m'attaque
en tout cas à beaucoup d'intérêts
puissants qui sont cités et c'est vrai
que
c'est pas que emmanuel macron
jeu
là j'attaque des sujets hyper sensibles
liées à la raison d'état je dévoile des
réseaux parfois très puissants notamment
dans la sphère de la communication dont
condé relais extrêmement puissant auprès
des médias français
tout ça pour un cd en double oui oui non
mais bon ça c'est la question du salaire
c'est anecdotique et
voilà donc bon c'est je suis pas sûr je
suis pas surpris de l'accueil du bouquin
en plus on est en pleine élection
présidentielle donc j'ai vu comment
l'élection présidentielle
qu'on ait vu comment elle cette élection
présidentielle un petit peu particulière
c'est c'est pas très étonnant
mais je suis quand même surpris de
dedieu visuel public nous et on va
rester neutre parce qu'après ça va
m'être reproché ce constat mais je
voudrais pas le seul
j'ai d'autres questions mais j'hésite à
les poser
quand on prend conscience de tous ces
sujets stratégiques pour notre pays
qu'on n'est pas nationaliste pour un sou
mais profondément patriote
qu'on a compris que il y avait des
preuves avec le pétrin qui avait des
projets clés terreur qui a des problèmes
avec les fertilisants donc y aller y
allait avoir des problèmes d'inflation
sur la bouffe sur les prix des tristes
et du chauffage du plastique des lacets
poncho sur des pulls des slips et j'en
passe et des meilleurs
qu'eux avec un tant soit peu de neurones
on arrive à connecter les petits points
et on se rend compte qu'on est sûr au
lit très très très très mauvaise pente
économique climatique
démographique et j'en passe et des
meilleurs
quand on se couche le soir quand on
ferme les yeux quand on est marc
endeweld il se passe quoi derrière les
paupières mais je dors bien
je dors très bien ça va vous vous
rappelez des cauchemars ou pas du tout
il m'est arrivé d'avoir quelques
cauchemars mais mais mais je m'en
rappelle assez peu en fait et il ya des
sous et très drôle mais je le vois là
pour moi mais mais mais voilà gestion
sinon je l'aurais bien
et sans rien prendre
à non strictement france il ya beaucoup
d'un coup ismo profession journalistique
nous ou qui prête à passer parce que
c'est une profession de la frustration
c'est
c'est très compliqué il faut c'est la
frustration du temps médiatique sa
frustration de pourquoi mon sujet a pas
eu la une pourquoi le rédacteur en chef
a pas voulu de mon sujet comme ça
pourquoi il a fallu changer le titre
pourquoi mes confrères ne me cite pas
pourquoi ceci pourquoi cela je parle
globalement je prends pas pour moi je
mais c'est toute cette frustration la c7
la frustation plus parce que la presse
française est dans une telle fragilité
économique et le métier devenu très
difficile pitt ut oui décrit petite faim
donc donc il ya le regard des gens tu as
un gir maintenant il y avait justement
pierre péan lors d'un précédent
précédent précédents rendez-vous il
m'avait dit tu devrais c'est comme tu
devrais négocier un gros avaloirs donc
comme ça ton livre sera diffusé et puis
tu auras des notes de frais et je les
regarde et je lui dis bah déjà je
m'appelle pas pierre péan et
deuxièmement
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas gp une
note de frais donc
si notre époque mais surtout c'est que
la profession est totalement
décrédibilisé auprès du public et du
public français alors les jeux les
il ya des raisons il ya plein de raisons
on en avait parlé à des 1 fois mais ça
aussi c'est que c'est
c'est
parfois j'hésite de dire je suis
journaliste pas
voilà il faut dire que vous travaillez
ou impôts ça marche pas et la blague
question internet monsieur de velde vous
est exceptionnel vous n'avez pas
quelques frayeurs avec certes ces
oligarques alors entre les lignes on n'a
pas à chercher à vous faire fermer un
peu vous de clapets vous n'a pas cherché
un petit peu vous achetez vous a pas
cherché un petit peu à vous mettre des
bâtons de reuil vous n'a pas cherché à
vous faire des petits croche-patte 1
commandé des campagnes de diffamation ou
à vous faire bloquer dans les rédactions
ou des choses comme ça
il ya eu un peu de tout ça
j'ai eu un peu de tout ça les les
communicants sont très forts pour avoir
des éléments de langage visant les
journalistes aujourd'hui
autre élément que je pourrais dire
les gens du mal à le percevoir enfin je
dis les gens si globalisation mais le le
le
j'ai travaillé sur la sarkozie sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande sur la
sarkozie j'ai été j'ai fait tout un
travail d' enquête sur les bygmalion
donc ça c'était après le pouvoir de
sarkozy mais j'avais travaillé soit
sarkozy
il ya les journalistes enquêtent ont
toujours en france ont toujours été
espionnées ont toujours été
on leur a toujours mis des bâtons dans
les roues des confrères davet l'homme
avait été les fameuse affaire des
fadettes
justement avec bernard squarcini
sauf que là il y à il ya deux problèmes
ni à 1 il ya des outils technologiques
aujourd'hui
donc notamment le scandale pegasus enfin
tous ces logiciels la
wii voilà et sa gelée voc alors je les
votes sous un angle géopolitiques ont
enfin on va en parler peut-être mais
dans le livre
et
comment
au delà pegasus comment des acteurs
privés des officines privées peuvent
avoir des moyens techniques d'espionnage
assez facilement avec les logiciels
voilà donc d'ailleurs sur l' affaire des
écoutes la fameuse affaire des écoutes
historique sous mitterrand
ou donc là c'était services de l'état
qui branchait les
différentes personnes à paris
il ya affaires sensibles l'émission de
france inter qui très bonne émission et
fabrice noël qui est maintenant passé à
là aussi en télé est l'un des premiers
numéros d'affaires sensibles en télé ils
ont fait un
documentaire sur l affaire des écoutes
trente ans après et ils ont invité
quelqu'un qui est apparu dans le cas de
la sphère benalla christian prouteau
anciens gendarmes de la cellule des gens
en armes c'est juste spécial de françois
mitterrand et proto pour se défendre
dans une interview un peu délirante mais
pour se défendre a dit
comme ça en passant et vous croyez que
ça s'est arrêté
voilà
donc ça ne s'est pas arrêté et ça passe
pas directement par les services de
l'état mais ça passe par des officines
privées
qui peuvent parfois être très intrusive
il sous pavillon étranger parfois oui je
travaille pour des intérêts étrangers
officines privées qui sont extrêmement
puissante sur la place de paris dans le
monde des affaires parisien en
particulier qui sont parfois protégé par
les services parce qu'ils rendent des
services aussi
et ses officines privées
on
également voilà
les fortes capacités de persuasion et de
l influence
pourquoi pourquoi il ya c'est par
déontologie mais peut-être pas pourquoi
il n'y a pas un journalisme maintenant
un peu plus sans foi ni loi qui
s'approprient les pegasus et août petit
petit bon bout du renseignement à
l'elysée l'a utilisé leurs moyens qu'on
leur convenance terre devenir plus court
aux yvan de venir à coeur
il faudrait que je me forme au code
alors même manière un vaincu
pourquoi il n'ya pas un journaliste plus
corrosif plus agressif plus invasif plus
offensif plus dans l'infiltration avec
ce côté bien patriotiques qui est vous
avez touché la france vous avez fait une
grossière erreur
c'est à dire je comprends pas là c'est à
dire c'est à dire devenir loup
devenir comme dirait plenel un
journaliste de combats un journaliste
guérilla pourquoi il y en a pas plus
droit il y en a pas plus qu yves qui
vous y en a mais il y en a pas plus
parce que on est bas ce sont les
confrères étrangers sont étonne toujours
on est sur un journalisme de souvent de
révérence les rédactions sont dirigés
par des journalistes politiques qui sont
dans la courtisanerie la plupart pour
des raisons de carrière donc l' enquête
n'a pas bonne presse en france
et donc on n'est pas du tout dans un
logiciel de contre-pouvoir comme dans
les pays anglo américains notamment ça
pose une question de transparence dans
la vie démocratique de nouveau mais
parce qu'en fait on est là pour le coup
pour reprendre les termes aux
néoconservateurs américains on est là
pour le coup on est un très très vieux
pis je trouvais
et on est dans l'essoufflement d'un
régime démocratique
c'est clair et donc pour revenir à la
période du quinquennat de lehman macron
il ya un élément j'avais évoqué la
dernière fois mais qui est très prégnant
comme le ni droite ni gauche a été le et
de droite de gauche entre guillemets je
parle pas de l'idéologie mais dans une
sorte de fourre tout
il ya tous les gens
qui soutiennent emmanuel macron ils ont
leurs raisons leur choix et compagnie
mais résultat tout houle tout le système
institutionnel mais également de presse
est un peu en léthargie et au delà même
de la question des oligarques en fait
dire que
[Rires]
il ya encore quelques semaines quelqu'un
me dit toute façon c'est mort macron
macron va gagner la prochaine
présidentielle donc çà çà çà çà çà
diminue les gens qui veulent continuer à
travailler uniquement sur un travail
d'information parce que la presse n'est
pas suffisant puis centre en france en
fait parce que je prends un exemple pour
que ce soit plus éclairant aux états
unis la presse a largement été donc
antitrust les pro by donne mais depuis
biden est devenu président des états
unis la presse même la plus installé
l'establishment américain heures times
du washington post à partir en fait
cadeau à bayonne
voilà on n'a pas parlé de la partie du
livre qui parle du coc vide et de
l'après connaissance de certaines
informations par vos services
est-ce que ont
d'abord un tout petit peu la partie
histoire de mettre en appétit vos futurs
lecteurs et on va faire 16 communes
spoil à bord
[Applaudissements]
alors
il faudra pas oublier un sujet qui me
tient à coeur dans le vivre
[Musique]
justement c'est un sujet
que j'étais que j'ai traité sur tout le
monde du livre qui est un peu sous
jacent à ce choc chine etats unis
mais en fait dans l'ombre et ç'a
toujours été le cas bien évidemment
mais encore plus ces dernières années
une disons une disjonction d'intérêt
stratégique de plus en plus évidents
entre israël et les états unis
mais on le voit sur plein de dossiers et
et on parlait tout à l'heure des de
certaines sources n'étaient pas formés
peuvent qui sont certaines fois mal
renseignés c'est très frappant de voir
qu'en france cet élément-là qui pourtant
central est pas totalement pris en
compte alors bien évidemment
israël les états unis sont toujours
allié mais la france et les états unis
sont toujours allié et pourtant il ya
des intérêts parfois divergents et dans
le cadre de cette relation particulière
entre isa les états unis il ya plein
d'épisodes que je relate dans le livre
notamment je replace la sphère pegasus
sous cet angle là
parce qu en fait
au delà de la révélation journalistique
il faut revenir
antérieurement à ce qui s'est passé sur
aisne et sow et les services de
renseignement américains et israéliens
en fait tout part en partie à la fois de
la ferc à choi à l'automne 2010
8,2 l'espionnage par le logiciel pegasus
par les saoudiens qui disposait du
logiciel pegasus de jeff bezos patron de
washington alors juste une parenthèse de
faire quelque chose qui s'est aux
journalistes saoudiens qui s'est fait
passer au mixeur dans une ambassade en
turquie au consulat
consulat saoudien d'istanbul
donc khashoggi
qui n'est pas issu de n'importe quelle
famille en arabie saoudite parce que la
famille khashoggi est une famille
d'intermédiaire et de marchands afin de
c'était des marchands d'armes donc il
était assis sur beaucoup de secrets
saoudiens généralement rappelle peut
donc effectivement khashoggi était
journaliste et notamment pour la presse
américaine
était devenu et se positionnait de plus
en plus comme opposant à mohammed bin
salman ce qui n'était pas forcément le
cas au début quand même dan salmane a
pris à partie le pouvoir
jeudi en partie parce qu'il est encore
le vieux père mais bon c'est lui qui est
l'homme fort du régime est
en fait il se passe quelque chose de
clés en 2019
c'est le fonds d'investissement
américain qu'avaient une bonne partie
qui contrôlait une bonne partie de nso
donc la société israélienne qui a
produit le logiciel espion pegasus ce
fonds américain très discrètement se
désengage à la hauteur rem d'un milliard
de dollars parce que c'est les
fondateurs de la nation enfin tout cas
certains fondateurs de l'année sont
toujours au capital et dirigeants qui
rachète à ce moment là pour un milliard
de dollars une partie des parts
et en fait donc ce fonds
d'investissement américain se désengage
et en fait dans ce que plusieurs sources
m'ont rapporté là pour le coup d'un
certain niveau c'est pas le fruit du
hasard
tout ça est lié à un contexte je lis dit
tendu j'ai lu sur plan géopolitique
entre israël et les états unis
on peut penser à la question du
moyen-orient
l'a récemment bien évidemment la
réouverture des négociations
avec l'iran
sans qu israël ait eu un mot à dire
le désengagement stratégique
américain du moyen orient comme
d'ailleurs aussi
d'autres marches de l'europe on parle de
l'ukraine en réalité ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de faux semblants là dedans
mais les américains près positionnent
leurs forces nous plus en plus en asie
ça c'est fait aussi très discrètement on
a énormément parlé de la sphère afghane
avec le retrait des troupes enfin
dernier élément américain en afghanistan
mais mais c'est plus large il ya un
désengagement stratégique beaucoup plus
large
et
et israël considère que sa sécurité plus
totalement assurée par le grand frère
américain allié américain bon ça c'est
un premier point deuxième point ils sont
sur deux stratégies divergentes
au regard
du continent américain vis-à-vis de la
chine la russie en gros israël considère
qu' il faut pas aller vers ça parce que
il ya encore beaucoup de collaborations
à voir avec la chine notamment en terme
de transfert de technologie en termes de
transfert de brevet et en termes de
business
et les américains ont signifié déjà
depuis très longtemps à israël arrêtez
vos transferts de technologies avec les
chinois arrêtés c'est ces éléments la
place à ce temps également entre les
deux il ya la question de l'afrique avec
les métaux rares
et puis
il ya également donc les questions de
l'énergie les etats-unis qui sont de
plus en plus autosuffisant sur les
énergies
carbonées pétrole de schiste gaz de
schiste
donc tous ces éléments fait que
structurellement il ya de plus en plus
une divergence
netanyahu quand il était au pouvoir
pendant très longtemps a fait le pari de
se rapprocher en fait de la russie de la
chine de l'inde
israël est très fort en termes de
stratégie géopolitique et géostratégique
très très fort c'est peut-être les
meilleurs aujourd'hui parce que en fait
je veux dire survivre oui oui tout à
fait c'est lié à leur histoire mais ils
ont une stratégie d'autonomie
stratégiques y compris vis-à-vis du
grand phare américain
et puis un élément de politique
intérieure américaine
c'est à dire que dans le choc biden
trump l'administration maiden le
département d'état le pentagone les
forces de renseignement américaine con
quand même largement soutenu mme hayden
face à trump ont décidé de l'incertain
découvre tout cas d'une tentative de
découplage sur certains dossiers on va
dire avec israël et avec israël qui a
encore peu de temps et est dirigé par
benyamin nétanyahou et comme on sait
cette proximité entre benyamin
nétanyahou et donald trump
et sur le long terme
[Rires]
les accords ça a donné les accords
d'abraham enfin plein d'éléments qui
amène israël à avoir davantage
d'hinterland d2 et de sécurité on va
dire dans l'espace régional en afrique
également et donc en fait sur tout un
tas de terrain ils sont de plus en plus
en compétition alors bien évidemment les
services de renseignements israéliens et
les services de renseignement américains
ont toujours à la fois collaborer de
manière très proche mais ont toujours
été dans la compet dans la compet et
dans la parfois dans la tension mais là
ces dernières années et notamment depuis
2010 neuf donc cesser concomitant au
choc chine etats unis en fait et
l'israël qui voudraient un peut être le
juge de paix de ce choc là en disant en
gros ils disent aux américains bah
peut-être que c'est pas la peine de vous
[__] sur la gueule avec la chine et
puis par ailleurs qui considère que les
américains essayent de se rapprocher de
la turquie de l'iran est toujours de
garder le pakistan c'est là si on
regarde géopolitiquement c'est toujours
la puissance maritime donc les états
unis qui essaye de casser
une tentative d'alliance des grandes
puissances sur le contenu continent
eurasiatique et donc là il ya deux chocs
stratégique très très fort parce que
bien évidemment israël reste
pour sa sécurité mais également dans un
logiciel de lutte notamment vis-à-vis de
l'iran sur la question nucléaire et donc
il ya ces tensions là est ce que ce que
j'ai découvert c'est que ça avait
forcément des implications diplomatiques
stratégiques
sur ce qui s'est passé en france depuis
deux trois ans
et la sphère pegasus d'ailleurs
éclate dans ce contexte là est en fait
dans le monde du renseignement en tout
cas dans les interlocuteurs j'ai pu
avoir
la plupart me confirme le fait que
la sphère pegasus intervient pas au
hasard certaine manière c'est les fameux
50 mille
téléphone numéro de téléphone qu'un
confrère qui connaît très bien ces
sujets là jean marc manach d'ailleurs a
fait des papiers pour expliquer mais est
ce que c'est bien sérieuses et 50000
téléphone parce que c'est ce qu'ils ont
vraiment été espionné enfin il a fait
plein de papiers il s'est posé plein de
questions sur est ce que c'est une
révélation qu'est ce que ça veut dire et
compagnie mais en fait ça a d'abord été
utilisé vrai vraiment en tout cas selon
mon analyse comme
un enjeu de soft power américain du sert
des services de renseignement américains
pour en gros si j'emploie un terme
trivial emmerder une partie des services
israéliens tout ça si croche-pied un
petit croche pied et autres croche pied
que j'évoque dans le livre guerres
africaines comment l'administration
d'haydn on parlait des réseaux de menad
des maynats nîmes netanyahu depuis
l'arrivée de baden pouvoir non en fait
c'est une guerre qui a qui a été
développé en amont de l'accession au
pouvoir de baden mais dans cette guerre
de l'ombre très très passionnante à
regarder
en
les administrations maiden à cibler
notamment deux oligarques israélien
proche de benyamin nétanyahou notamment
dans le gat l'air qui a des activités de
mines en république démocratique du
congo et benny steinmetz et tout ça est
important à prendre en compte parce que
justement on parlait des
néoconservateurs tout à l'heure au quai
d'orsay enfin certains néo conservateurs
au quai d'orsay en fait on est en train
d'assister à ce que j'appelle la fin du
consensus néoconservateurs les
démocraties occidentales face à l'ennemi
de l'islam et ça ce et on est là au
coeur des nouvelles luttes
géostratégiques et géopolitiques ou
chine
etats unis russie au 6 mai et israël
joue des partitions qui sont totalement
différentes
ou en tout cas relativement différente
des réflexes de relations
internationales
et donc on a pu encore avoir dans le
passé encore très proche tout ça dans un
contexte géopolitique où on est au monde
d'énergie on manque de matière première
cuillère réchauffement climatique qui va
créer des événements exotiques pas du
tout fédérateur
une belle partie aux perspectives et
est-ce que sous-estiment les européennes
à mon point de vue c'est stupidité de
ses élites non non les leur inertie
compris en termes de grille de lecture
du monde et de leur lune a ils ont ils
devraient aller chez le petit enfant à
l'opticien chez l'ophtalmo quoi ils
devraient adapter leur vision parce que
alors je pense qu emmanuel macron est ok
conscient de tout ça pour le coup si si
il ya des j'ai dit conscient j'ai pas
dit qu'il avait une stratégie est ce que
justement tout mon livre montrent qu'il
est ballotté qui est perdu et qui en
fait il est très inquiet sans face à
ceux bascule cette bascule mais non
c'est dans ses différentes interventions
diplomatiques et je pense notamment à
une interview qu'il a donnée à ces
économistes en l'automne 2010 9 où il
parle de l'
état de mort cérébrale de l'otan
il dit des choses assez intéressantes
sur justement la bascule du monde sur le
fait que le bloc occidental a éclaté
donc le conte en fait il est conscient
que le consensus néo conservateur a
éclaté en fait emmanuel macron est
conscient de ça
et et d'ailleurs ça explique pourquoi au
moment de son élection en 2017 il est
dans le en même temps c'est à dire
autour de lui il a des anciens
diplomates qui le soutiennent et il a la
foi des néoconservateurs georges aarau
par exemple même s'il veut pas se
qualifier néo conservateurs mais bon il
l'a été et de l'autre côté il a
également des gaules au mitterrandien
genre hubert védrine
et tous le conseil et à l'époque on
comprend pas trop pourquoi il ya tous
ces gens là c'est avec ces sensibilités
diverses qui sont autour d' emmanuel
macron mais je pense parce que je pense
en fait parce que emmanuel macron est
conscient de ces tensions la et
notamment des tensions entre israël et
les états unis
je pense qu'il est conscient de ça après
est ce que ça fait
l'objet d'une vraie stratégie pour la
france c'est autre chose
voilà parce que en gros la question
c'est où et qu'elle lui quel carton
enfin quel jeu on joue nous 20 h 10 nous
la france voilà avec le petit père de
deux qui nous reste dans la bouche
il faut voir aussi les prétentions oui à
notre niveau et vous où il faut bluffé
est-ce qu'on peut bluffer que les russes
aient eu le chic vos fins peut-être pas
trop non non pas d'ailleurs on le voit
avec l'ukraine il a essayé de faire le
conciliateur mais ce que je raconte dans
le livre css est racontée en longueur
dans un tout un chapitre
ça fait bien longtemps que les russes ne
prennent pas au sérieux et emmanuel
macron malgré ses tentatives de dialogue
et compagnie d'ailleurs on l'a vu encore
mario derrière c'est pire que ça il ya
un rien derrière mais il est comme il
est comme il est considéré comme pas
fiable par les partenaires parce qu'ils
changent de position tous les quatre
matins et on comprend pas trop pourquoi
parfois même moi des fois j'ai déjà du
mal à analyser et sur le dossier russe
très clairement
c'est que emmanuel macron a été
notamment s'est opposée pour des raisons
là pour le coup
d'intérêt national direct manière s'est
opposé au projet nord stream 2 notamment
auprès de bruxelles dès 2019 face à
l'allemagne qui avait un intérêt un
avantage comparatif est en fait emmanuel
macron certains acteurs et analystes ont
cru qu'ils s'alignent elle a sur les
états unis en fait il s'agit n'est pas
sur les états unis il défend des justes
son bout de gras entre guillemets l2
garde la france pour le coup face à la
stratégie gazière de l'allemagne qui a
l'ambition d'être un hub gaziers sur
l'europe entière et donc de monnayer
cette position de biase et sur l'europe
entière et notamment vis-à-vis de
l'italique eu un tel un souci parce
qu'ils sont encore ils ont encore une
industrie importante contrairement à la
france et donc voilà est donc là il ya
un enjeu important qui aboutit à deux
constats du livre d'ailleurs là pour le
coup très factuelle et très clinique
c'est que tout le monde parle du groupe
franco-allemand enfin les commentateurs
notamment beaucoup en france beaucoup
plus qu'en allemagne d'ailleurs on a la
prétention dans l'égalité de l'allemagne
alors que l'allemagne ça plein
d'économies se montre
est largement plus
puissante surprend économique alors on
dit toujours la france à l'armée la
bombe nucléaire et tout ça et tout ça
mais dans les faits il ya des
divergences stratégiques et sur le
dossier énergétique qui sont
considérables entre la france et
l'allemagne est d'ailleurs quand
emmanuel macron parle d'ordre de la
défense en fait de l'autre côté les
allemands continuent à acheter des armes
américaines et des f-35 comme d'autres
partenaires européens donc là on voit
bien que on et voilà on voit bien que il
se réfugie dans un certain standing de
puissance on va dire ça comme ça au nom
de l'europe est en réalité dans les
faits ça ça n'a pas fonctionné durant
tout son quinquennat pour plein de
raisons que j'évoque d'ailleurs dans le
livre et dont je reviens à la russie
comme il s'est opposé à nord stream 2
auprès de bruxelles valley russe le
savent et vladimir poutine mais ça y est
c'est donc en fait c'est pour ça qu'ils
le prennent pas totalement sérieux parce
que pour eux c'est un casus belli la
question du gaz bien évidemment et puis
pour en rajouter au bazar
ça je les dis quelquefois de ces
derniers jours quand j'ai eu des
interventions médiatiques c'est que la
france a aussi d'énormes intérêts gazier
et pétrolier en russie
parce que total total dont deux tombes
parle jamais jean ne marche jamais
totale c'est quand même elle c'est le
délire total c'est le cas de le dire est
totale on ne parle jamais de total alors
que total
d'ailleurs du fait notamment ça c'est
très intéressant mais après on va finir
sur la bôme et c'est très intéressant
totale quand elf aquitaine était dirigé
par loïk le floch prigent
a fait le choix déjà petit à petit se
désengager du continent africain et a
fait le choix d'amenuiser les apports de
gaz venant de l'algérie
c'est important ça ce que je dis et
est en fait sur le temps long
l'industrie pétrolière mais également
gazière parce que total a bouffé est en
train de bouffer angie 1 ils ont racheté
toutes les activités gnl d' angie qui
étaient en fait les activités
historiques de gnl de gaz de france
total notamment sous christophe de
margerie s'est de plus en plus
rapprochées delà de la russie au point
d'avoir 24 % des réserves prouvées du
groupe donc un quart des réserves
prouvées du groupe en pétrole gaz sont
présentes en russie 17 % ça ces chiffres
2020 de mémoire 17% de la d2 la
production pétrole gaz de total c'est la
russie et notamment ils ont énormément
investi dans le site de yamal
qui en sibérie ça signifie la fin de la
terre
comme mon nom d'ailleurs ça
c'était il ya mal il ya tout un site
d'extraction de gaz et surtout de
transformation de gaz en gnl pour à la
fois exporter par un gazoduc qui va en
europe mais surtout par bateau gnl
d'ailleurs le premier bateau était nommé
l'histoire est en jeu christophe de
margerie et total
contrôle 30% diamal ainsi qu'un autre
site qui a été ouvert qui est en train
d'être ouverts en phase de yamal sur un
groupe plus que bon vouloir du tarif
voilà et total donc est totalement
imbriquée dans l'oligarchie lisation
poutinienne et surtout du système russe
parce que c'est pas et on fait poutine
un homme parfois un peu trop fort au
regarde de la collégialité du pouvoir en
russie c'est beaucoup plus compliqué on
peut le croire et d'ailleurs margerie
françois fillon quand il était premier
ministre puis même françois hollande
parce que jean pierre jouyet tu es très
proche parent de par sa famille de
christophe de margerie la famille
taittinger donc sa femme fait partie
c'est une teinte c'était un sujet
taittinger
dont la les intérêts privés total les
intérêts publics français ont négocié
pour que l'acteur total associé un
acteur russe qui s'appelle novatek qui
en fait le deuxième producteur de gaz
après gazprom puissent
eux-mêmes exporter du gaz en concurrence
de gazprom
et ça ça a été une petite révolution
parce que c'est vladimir poutine et
medvedev qui ont accepté à ce qu'un
autre groupe privé associé au groupe
privé français total puisse exporter du
gaz
ce qui implique beaucoup de choses parce
que les oligarques qui étaient autour de
gazprom il était vraiment pas content
mais vraiment pas content du tout lukla
il ya eu une guerre d'influencé au sein
de l'état russe est la conséquence pour
la france aujourd'hui c'est que dans le
dossier ukrainien où le gaz est aussi
central il n'y a pas que les raisons
stratégiques et qui a pas que les
raisons démocratiques liée à al crenn et
plein de plein d'autres raisons qu'on
évoque alors à longueur de temps c'est
que les états unis quand il parle de
sanction c'est pas uniquement contre
north stream ii s'est également contre
total et yamal
et là je vous donne je vous donne un
petit petit couple enfin
d'ailleurs j'allais j'allais en faire
enfin je vais en faire ma chronique ce
soir si j'ai le temps de l'écrire ce
soir en rentrant ma chronique pour la
tribune un des éléments de discussion
que poutine et macro eu
la semaine dernière quand ils se sont
rencontrés avec la grande table et ben
poutine a parlé de yamal et total donc
donc le jeu diplomatique français est à
la fois plus complexe plus difficile
pour un président de la république
française surtout comme un état dans
l'état c'est à dire je parlais de la
firme pétrolière total là quand quand
total et dans le dans le paysage
maîtresse d'une manière très surprenante
sur le dossier russe ukrainien on
n'arrête pas de parler du gaz et du
gazoduc ukrainien de nord stream 2 on
parle jamais derrière de tueur stream
qui passe par la turquie et qui pourtant
approvisionne l'europe et apporte du gaz
russe à la turquie et à l'europe on dit
jamais que la turquie d'ailleurs est
totalement sous la dépendance du gaz
russe à plus de 70% et on ne parle
jamais du site yamal en partie financée
par des capitaux chinois qui apporte
aujourd'hui du gaz gnl en europe et un
peu partout dans le monde et le fait que
ce gaz gnl russo français entrent
totalement en compétition avec le gnl
américain
ben alors voilà donc
c'est papin là pour le coup si je
reviens à la thématique du livre sur la
guerre froide économique en cours
c'est assez intéressant parce que en
fait les américains sur l'arc est
de l'europe
ils ont joué plein de jeu de bonneteau
ldans parce que en fait ils ont monté
ils ont donné plein de signes aux
européens depuis quelques temps déjà y
compris d'un désengagement des forces
stratégiques du côté européen
et non là il ya eu tout un théâtre et il
ya toujours des tensions très fortes
diplomatiques et des mouvements de
troupe et donc
c'est très compliqué actuellement reste
que en fait dans les faits les états
unis sont plutôt en train de se
désengager de l'espace
donc
alors il ya un élément très important
pour revenir au nucléaire
c'est que ça c'est un interlocuteur
aussi que kim a expliqué tout ça
c'est que on parle du gaz et des comptes
du contentieux gazier historique depuis
15 ans 15 ans bientôt entre l'ukraine et
la russie mais il ya un sujet sur lequel
l'ukraine et la russie ne se sont jamais
ça sur lequel ne sont jamais venir
[__] sur la gueule
c'est le nucléaire parce que les
centrales nucléaires du crânienne sont
deux conceptions de russes son camp ce
conception russe et donc toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et en partie russe
est par ailleurs l'ukraine exporte de
l'électricité vers la russie donc là
aussi il ya beaucoup plus
d'interdépendance compense entre
l'ukraine et la russie ce qui est normal
vu qu'il y ait les deux états sont issus
d'une union soviétique puis aussi
l'histoire ancienne mais donc
moi ce qui me frappe et j'en parle de
total dans le livre et du site yamal et
de l'histoire et christophe de margerie
c'est que quand on évoque la question
gazière et l'europe on parle seulement
de certains gazoduc on parle jamais de
total et on ne parle jamais là pour le
coup si on revient à la france du fait
que
deux choses
le gaz et ça c'est les allemands qui ont
l'ont poussé à bruxelles va être
considérée comme une énergie dite verte
ce qui est quand même la blague parce
que c'est une énergie carbonée alors les
nucléocrates et le lobby du nucléaire
dit pas regarder c'est pas possible nous
c'est climat
encore un autre sujet mais il ya ce
débat là un très clair et on devient de
plus en plus dépendants du gaz russe
pour deux raisons parce que les
dirigeants européens ont pas du tout
anticipé l'affaiblissement des réserves
dans mer du nord en norvège pour que
c'était mort qui pourtant c'est
important il y avait
plus avisés lumière dans tous les sens
depuis 20 ans et par ailleurs la france
aurait pu jouer la carte algérienne même
si le gaz algérien aussi va en
s'amenuisant
pour des raisons mais pour des raisons
aussi de ceux investis de son
investissement de sous investissement en
gazier et pétrolier en algérie donc
c'est pas que les réserves en fait et
puis il ya aussi un autre élément c'est
que la sonatrach à la société algérienne
est très liée aux américains
historiquement au pétrolier texan et aux
républicains tout ça est au site est
incomplet qui tenaient du complexité et
emmanuel macron je parlais de
l'intuition a parfois eu des intuitions
autre chose moi je passais un coup de
chance dans le dernier livre mais là je
reparle des relations de cette boîte
noire entre l'algérie et la france avec
les oligarques avec toutes les questions
que l'on peut se poser sur le voyage de
macron en algérie en février 2017 mais
une de ses intuitions c'était ça se
passe que il assez vieux conseillers qui
ont connu mitterrand mythe la doctrine
mitterrand dans le gaz c'était la règle
des trois tiers enfin tu étais pas
vraiment des tiers en fait mais un tiers
à la mer du nord un tiers les russes et
un tir l'algérie avec un contrat gaz de
france publique à l'époque
présenté comme relativement favorable
aux algériens et donc j'évoquais elf
aquitaine total qui sont désengagés
petit à petit de l'afrique et surtout
l'algérie
emmanuel macron je sais qu'en février
2010 est en fait discuter d'un projet de
gazoduc issus du nigeria de lagos
exactement qui allie potentiellement
passerait à travers le sahara pour
arriver jusqu'en algérie
qui permettrait à l'algérie si elles
disposaient de ce gazoduc de faire
remonter donc du gaz des poches de gaz
du nigeria qui aujourd'hui fournie à peu
près quand même je crois à 9% 8% la
france déjà mais en gnl en bateau et ça
permettrait à l'algérie de continuer à
bénéficier un peu de cette rente
pétrolière et gazière sauf que l'algérie
a face à elle qui le maroc
qui souhaitent faire un gazoduc le long
et qui existent en partie qui en fait un
gazoduc qui longe les côtes africaines
et qui passe dans tous les pays
africains et bien évidemment là il ya un
choc très important économique qui
explique d'ailleurs les tensions en
algérie ces derniers mois
multiples et variées aux différents
acteurs étrangers ont joué une partie la
turquie israël les américains
je pourrais continuer un petit coup sûr
nul à bourgoin oui on va terminer sur ça
j'suis pas justement ça qui est beau
histoire de metron de petty
alors effectivement donc comment
j'arrive sur ce sujet là parce qu'on
vous dit
enfin franchement
alors j'arrive sur ce sujet là parce
qu'en fait je ne sais pas j'ai j'ai
passé mes sources enfin c'est
alors je vais raconter les choses
simplement
enfin j'espère j'étais simple jusqu'à
présent ma forme va avoir à compter les
choses simplement telles qu'elles se
sont passées pour moi
en fait en janvier 2020
je suis tenu au courant par des sources
en contact elle même deux sources
participant aux réunions de crise à l'om
est ce
de la situation de la pandémie avenir qu
janvier avant de 15 minutes aux
alentours du 15
très tôt et qu'est ce que me disent ces
sources à l'époque que la situation est
déjà hors contrôle donc ça ça voulait
dire que le petit virus se baladait déjà
dans toute la planète donc ça servait à
rien de fermer les frontières
mais ça on ne l'a pas expliquer aux
français ce qui peut en partie si je
fais l'avocat du diable en partie
s'expliquer tuant la crainte des
gouvernants de la panique mais bon ça
c'est un argument kabondo notamment dans
un cadre démocratique parce qu'à un
moment donné il suffit d'expliquer les
choses et on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur les
différentes décisions sanitaires la
plupart du temps les français ont été
d'un civisme incroyable on pourrait dire
certains pourraient dire même une
apathie parfois sur certaines libertés
publiques réduites comme une peau de
chagrin
donc je reviens en janvier 2001 est donc
en janvier 2010 on me dit que la
situation est déjà contrôler
que le principal vecteur transmission
c'est l'aérosol isation
alors que l'état français mettra plus de
neuf mois le reconnaître
se basant sur les states et les
déclarations officielles de l'om s mais
là il faut aussi qu'ils vont le chili
mais il faut être en partie le lobby des
chinois mais a dû jeter de la chine mais
pas que il faut comprendre que l'om est
un organe sanitaire mais c'est un organe
politique et financier comme et financé
par plein de capitaux mais pas que
chinois il ya aussi les américains l'un
d'eux met
donc les les communications officielles
et aider les alertes de l' oms sont
toujours un consensus politique et
diplomatique internationale en fait et
donc moi je déjà je comprenais pas parce
qu'il y avait la communication
officielle de l'om est-ce donc notamment
par exemple sur les masques et de
l'autre côté j'avais les vraies
discussions
dans les réunions de crise les ems
donc j'étais un titre personnel j'étais
un petit peu inquiet surtout quand on
veut aussi parler juste après j'avais
d'ailleurs une source qui vit à
l'étranger avec voilà qui m'avait alerté
et qui m'avait dit quand même en passant
j'achète un masque à gaz
la source n'est pas hypocondriaque
des doutes le pays dans le golfe
et
et le troisième élément qui pourrait
apparaître polémique mais depuis mon
travail d enquête j'ai récupéré des
éléments précis et écrits de gens qui
ont participé à ces réunions de crise à
l'om s en tout cas les premiers éléments
d'information comme nan dès janvier 2020
c'est que la séquence du virus est
qualifiée de suspecte
alors moi dans le livre je ne vais pas
dans un sens ou dans un autre juge
explique que j'ai à la fois recueillie
est donc dans un sens ou dans un autre
est-ce que ça c'est le débat
scientifique est ce que c'est une
zoonose donc un réservoir naturel avec
une transmission passage de barrières
l'espèce à l'homme ou six coups sûrs
tout aussi ah oui ça préalable aussi
c'est une fuite de laboratoire reste que
contrairement quand même parce que là
aussi il faut quand même pas prendre les
gens pour des imbéciles je suis désolé
en au début de la pandémie en termes de
communication gouvernementale comme en
termes de relais du corps médical
français
qui n'est pas forcément d'ailleurs
virologues il faut quand même le
rappeler il certains des infectiologues
mais les médecins sont pas forcément des
scientifiques qui connaissent les
laboratoires de plus ou moins grande
sécurité ce qui me petit aparté mais le
discours à l'époque ça ça a été ensuite
maintes fois racontée le discours
officiel était ça ne peut pas être une
fuite de la beaux
buts il ya la fameuse il ya le fameux
article qui donne le la l'article 2 alan
cet
initié comme on le sait maintenant la
presse américaine la dénoncer et l'a
révélé par peter d'azac
qui organise tout une opération de
communication produire ça peut pas être
la fille de la bo attention si vous
dites que c'est une fuite de la boue
vous est catégorisé
donc je reste prudent les deux les deux
thèses
c'est le débat scientifique qui n'est
toujours pas tranchée du fait aussi de
l'opacité des autorités chinoises qui ne
donne pas tous les éléments du fait
également de l'opacité des autorités
américaines et françaises
pourquoi on se demande bien pourquoi
donc est ce qu'un jour on aura à la les
éléments de réponse je ne sais pas en
tout cas moi pourquoi je m'intéresse aux
sujets déjà un parce qu'en fait ça
percute mon objet d' enquête déjà de
l'époque j'ai dit j'ai commencé à
enquêter sur chine etats unis france dès
l'automne 2010 neuf donc arrive la
pandémie
donc je travaille sur ça et puis comme
d'abus comme je voulais rien révélé et
expliquer dès janvier 2020 on me donne
ces éléments là moi je me souviens très
bien parce que à l'époque
donc il y avait toute la la
communication il y avait un ace busin
jour sont bien s'en souvient et écrit en
février 2020
moi qui connaît bien la macro ni et puis
qui fait aussi des sujets politiques
des papiers politique
eh bien il ya eu la sphère griveaux
milieu où tout tout petit pareil s'est
excité sur quand même une histoire de
sextape là pour le coup il ya beaucoup
de correspondances à une petite histoire
du oui ça on en revient à un autre jour
peut-être parce que je commence à
fatiguer mais ça ressemble au film don't
look up là pour le coup alors que le
monde va basculer mais on parle d'une
sextape en gros c'est à peu près ça donc
ça fait vraiment il ya des points de
correspondance avec le film de netflix
désolé pour la pub et
donc je me souviens très bien que
à mon petit niveau dès lors que l' oms a
commencé à avoir les premières alertes
les plus sérieusement courant février au
moment de l'affairé rivaux je laisse un
tweet enfin je fais un tweet et je fais
un statut facebook le statut facebook
est un petit peu plus alarmistes parce
que je dis que le virus se transmet par
l'air
et à l'époque je me fais engueuler par
10 contacts facebook en disant mais tu
as l'air tout le monde pourquoi tu dis
ça tu allais remise était toujours des
listes parce qu'il ouvrait eu la même
chose à peu près 25 janvier donc en tout
cas bah moi je répondais piteusement bas
ses sources et au msc mes sources quoi
donc vous en faites ce que vous voulez
et je n'ai fait je n'ai fait en tout et
pour tout à l'époque qui même après par
la suite que c'est ce que ces tweets là
après je me suis parfois peut-être
énervé comme citoyens sur des aspects de
politique sanitaire mais ça c'est autre
chose
sur certains caractère ubuesque que des
polonais des décisions totalement
contradictoires parfois mais ça c'est
encore autre chose mais en tout cas pour
revenir au calendrier de l'enquète
en janvier 2020 en fait quand je
rencontre des sources parfois très
informés à paris et quand je ne je ne
souhaite pas alors certains on me
regarde comme un fou mais sauf que je
j'avais des éléments sérieux qui
m'amenait à penser que sa lettre le gros
bordel et qu'on allait donc vers un
confinement
donc c'est ça le point de départ de mon
enquête donc il est double en fait parce
que
à la fois je me suis intéressé au
calendrier
est donc là on n'est pas sur l'origine
du virus en tant que tel en tant que tel
mais sur le calendrier de à partir de
quand les autorités françaises ont été
été au courant décembre 2019 non
officiellement agnès buzyn a alerté
visite au
ministère de la défense ce que je
découvre alors j'ai assuré le
contradictoire j'ai envoyé un mail
à 10 codes services de communication des
armées
j'ai vu un officier qui m'a répondu on a
bien reçu votre mail
on
froisse signe ils m'ont jamais répondu
d'ailleurs depuis j'ai écrit ce fameux
chapitre un peu détonnant qui explique
peut-être la gêne certains frères
j'ai pas eu de ma part fait passer le
message
donc pas de démenti officiel pas de
démenti of pas de pas d'ambiance âge
tu veux bien bas quand vous approchent
et qu'on vous donne des éléments
pourraient essayer de vous éclairer de
vous influencer sur votre analyse de
deux surfeurs du goût de dieu oui non
non non ils vont pas en tout cas voilà
silence depuis ça fait un mois a
pratiquement que le bouquin et le livre
est sorti silence est ce que je dis dans
le livre parmi les révélations donc là
que je glisse je pense que je le spoil
un petit peu c'est que j'apprends que
les services français de renseignements
lentement même si la dgse rose en
particulier la drm la direction les
actions des renseignements militaires
mais on me parle également de la dame
c'est quelque chose qui apparaît de
manière très importante dans l'enquêté
que j'ai pas encore évoqué donc la dame
c'est la direction des applications
militaires c'est la direction une des
dirigeants et plus confidentiels dans
l'état français qui a pallié totalement
renseignements mais qui est liée à la
force de dissuasion nucléaire c'est la
direction des applications militaires
qui gère force de dissuasion nucléaire
est
en fait qu auraient été mandatées je
mets du conditionnel je reste prudent
mais dès l'automne 2010 9 pour savoir ce
qui se passait à one
alors là j'ai différentes versions on me
dit aux responsables de renseignements
que j'ai interrogé me dit oui on a
commencé à regarder après les jeux de
roanne les jeux militaires
j'ai d'autres sources qui me disent
qu'en gros qui vont même plus loin parce
que elles me disent que
aurait profité des jeux militaires pour
essayer de savoir un peu plus ce qui se
passait à one alors ouais on l'a peu dit
mais c'est une ville très particulière
pour la france parce que c'est la
princesse avec shanghai pour d'autres
raisons historiques mais c'est la
principale porte d'entrée économique
politique presque de plus générale
depuis le général de gaulle ça s'est
renforcée sous valéry giscard d'estaing
notamment
principale porte d'entrée de la france
en chine bon derrick là parce que sinon
ça va ce poulet jusqu'au bout
vous avez trois bouquins conseiller de
te sinon je raconte plein de choses sur
sur la pandémie sur le labo est un
élément dernier c'est que
sur le transfert de technologie du
fameux laboratoire bsl
4,3 et tous les autres petits qui vous
fait que voilà il ya les baies -celles
deux baies -celles 3 tous à son mais ce
qui nous implique ray la france dans
cette histoire c'est le bsl 4 donc c'est
celui qui est le plus sensible c'est
celui où la france a transféré
technologie de confinement est un aspect
de déclare à l'historique pour
comprendre la complexité de ces dossiers
comme l'incident nucléaire civil de
taishan c'est qu'on est totalement dans
la raison d'état parce que c'est des
secteurs déjà totalement stratégique
et pourquoi parce que l'acs la
technologie du confinement p4 à la fois
est une technologie duale civile et
militaire mais ailleurs notre
technologie la technologie française p4
est totalement relié à l'aventuré
nucléaire française parce qu'en fait la
technologie de confinement appliquée et
10 le qui a été mis à disposition des
chercheurs en virologie en biologie
c'est en fait de la technologie de
confinement qu'on avait utilisé
précédemment dans notre programme
nucléaire militaire et civile et donc il
ya une imbrication total c'est pour ça
que je parlais de la dame cette activité
cette direction des applications
militaires puisqu'en fait il ya une
implication totale de la technologie et
des
techniciens
qui met au point cette technologie
baissent elles quatre dans le domaine
biologique en france du nucléaire et
d'ailleurs
pour finir sur ça
deux choses
nous avons en fait trois bsl cats sur le
territoire français un civil a lyon je
rapportais je relaie toute l'histoire
comme d'autres papiers de presse l'ont
fait mais avec des éclairages différents
parfois
et de bsl quatre militaires en essonne
donc pas loin d'ici
l'un à brétigny qui est sous tutelle la
direction de santé des armées enfin
c'est un autre sigle herbages plus que
ça veut dire exactement et l'autre sur
le site du boucher qui étrenne un petit
village de l'essonne et pour la petite
histoire c'est le site du boucher était
en fait le premier site du nucléaire
militaire français parce que c'est là où
il ya eu les premières centrifugeuses
après la seconde guerre mondiale pour
permettre à la france de disposer de
plutonium pour créer la bombe pour vous
dire la la sensibilité de ces domaines
là est d'ailleurs
l'actuel patron du bsl cat de lyon
monsieur raoul a pas confondre avec le
lean arables out le monsieur raoul hervé
raoul je crois qu'ils affiliés inserm
enfin en tout cas qui dirige le bsl cat
de lyon est en fait à l'origine au fond
enfin un haut fonctionnaire de la
défense
il travaillait à la dame à la direction
des applications militaires donc on est
dans un domaine d'une opacité extrême
parce que je fais le constat dès le
début du livre et on parlait de la
colonisation au cours de l'entretien
l'un des derniers fermant de puissance
entre guillemets dans la mythologie
républicaine et de la vème république et
de 7 de ce régime présidentialiste le
dernier ferment de puissance c'est la
force de dissuasion nucléaire que le
crew voulu en anglais que d'ailleurs
macron quand il était banquier chez
rothschild et membre de la deuxième
commission attali membre à plein de la
deuxième commission attali effectivement
c'est une des révélations du livre
avait proposé au désamour des autres aux
autres membres de la commission attali
pour faire des économies la suppression
la force du dictionnaire nuit lundi tu
t'est ptit parce que ça qui garantit
notre siège voilà et jacques attali et
participant donc ça c'est une des
anecdotes du livre puis fait la leçon à
l'époque
et
il a évolué depuis on voit d'ailleurs
que la question de la force de missions
de nuit claire peut faire débat ça a été
soulevée par mélenchon avec la la
question du spatial mais ça s'il dit ça
c'est parce que il a rencontré des
justement des hauts fonctionnaires de la
défense qui se pose beaucoup de
questions sur le plan stratégique donc
il dit il dit pas ça comme ça c'est pas
venu dans ce petit cerveau c'est parce
qu'il ya des gens qui se posent des
questions sur la pertinence encore de
notre action stratégique par rapport aux
forces nucléaires y compris sur la
prolifération de différents armes
nucléaires de moindre intensité ça je
vais pas aux vrais encore notre dossier
mais c'est aussi un problème de valises
et voilà et donc pour revenir à
l'ope voilà pour revenir en labo voilà
et pour venir au constat de ce ferment
de puissance la du nucléaire de
l'importance du nucléaire dans la
l'organisation étatique fait que ça
explique aussi beaucoup pourquoi l'état
français
sur tout un tas de sujets ultrasensibles
son reste dans un silence important et
dans une opacité important puisqu'en
fait la culture qui prime c'est celle de
la raison d'état donc ça après
j'apporte plein d'autres éléments sur
l'histoire havrin
voilà
lorsque livre
où il faut leur montrer ok on va faire
travailler au pq mais voilà ça fait
vraiment promo un comique
et
est en tout cas sur le
sur le calendrier
de la de l'info jusqu'à quel point
l'elysée étaient au courant et à partir
de quel moment c'est quand même
relativement intéressant quand on sait
que la haute cour de justice
se penche sur le sujet et tout le monde
vise agnès buzyn qui de mon point de vue
ressemble plus à un beau fusible
belle bookbook beau j'arrive plus à
parler un bouc-émissaire densité si
cette histoire là parce que en fait pour
revenir au service des enseignants
vraisemblablement le ministère des
centres de la santé a été contournée sur
le sur le dossier de la pandémie au
début de la pandémie ce qui explique
aussi un autre éclairage la nôtre jour
le fait qu ensuite tous et tout était
réglé dans le cas d'un des fameux
conseil de la défense et de défense à
l'elysée sous fameux sucré avec eux on
retrouve ce secret défense le secret
défense la raison d'état et donc
voilà un moment donné il faudra
peut-être ouvrir les archives à 150
sarkozy tout petit peu
tout ça pour expliquer certaines
personnes s'étonnent du silence
et du malaise du débat fuite de labo pas
fils de labo 1 rappelant effectivement
que ça peut très bien sortir d'un labo
qui n'est pas celui du best quelques
baisses alcatel sur
le donc le débat scientifique à continue
mais l'extrême prudence sur le sujet
vient de tout ce contexte là qui est
quand même assez intéressant à découvrir
mais c'est pas la seule information sur
le sujet parce qu'on n'a pas tout
spoiler un gars on va sous les 1 600
points
tous trois livres un conseiller d'autres
communautés
j'avais oublié cette question
pas de lier question oui à
je crois qu est ce que j'ai lu récemment
j'ai commencé à lire un polar mais alors
je sais plus le titre mains
d'un ancien confrères de médiapart
j'espère je l'appelle coché son nom de
thomas cantaloube que fait heins qui
s'est lancé dans l'écriture de polars et
c'est plutôt pas mal notamment ça se
passe sous la guerre en algérie non ça
il faut vous vous retrouviez le titre
parce que ça c'est une deuxième un
deuxième
ça je pourrais trouver frentzen bouquin
que j'ai lu aussi pour le livre
passionnant
qu'est ce que je pourrais
qu'est-ce-qui caisse clic et plein de
livres là ça va trop vite ben on a
évoqué payant les
l'autobiographie de peyrens fait
intéressant sur c'est aussi un peu on
est aussi une manière qu'il a eu 20 c
ces notes il s'est présenté une certaine
manière donc c'est assez intéressant et
et le et j'ai pas encore lu mais je vous
le conseille avant de l'avoir lu
parce que ça m'a l'air très intéressant
et je laisse à la maison le nouveau
bouquin de guillaume pitron justement
sur
sur les métaux rares non le nouveau
bouquin qui est sur l'ajustement
l'infrastructure d'internet et du
numérique
alors il parle pas exactement lorsque je
crois de ce que je vous ai raconté la
sur l'enseignement mais il parle bien
évidemment d d d une partie sur les
câbles sous-marins surtout il parle des
centres de données de l'énergie qu'il
faut fournir à tous ses centres de
données et donc de l' architecture
mondiale et des enjeux géopolitiques
automne est électrique il ya des
dirigeants qui est en train de me dire
que j'ai aucune pitié avec vous que vous
n'avez pas un verre d'eau vous montrez
le verre d'eau avec caméra et un verre
d'eau là
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
quelque chose une bouteille à la bbc
temps c'est votre côté catho de gauche
est une
façon attentes
non toute droite ils ont pas 2,6 ha
non c'est pour le conseil aux jeunes
générations
puisque c'est un côté patrice raulin ah
oui
qu'est ce que je peux dire banon mais
informez-vous quoi voilà faites l'effort
de vous informer mais ils le font ils le
font les femmes enfin certains en tout
cas surtout d'où deux communautés voilà
je sais marc endeweld merci
[Musique]